hey everyone welcome to this react js
full course video
react is a javascript library used to
create fancy user interfaces for mobile
and desktop applications
it is widely used and is preferred over
other frameworks for front-end
development
so if you wish to learn web development
then you are in the right place
this video covers all the necessary
topics to give you a good understanding
of react and some of its concepts
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what's in store for you
we'll begin with a quick introduction to
react and then move ahead with react
installation on windows
later we'll look at some of the
fundamental concepts like react
components
props and state
then we'll build an application from
scratch using react after that we look
at a comparison between javascript
frameworks like angular view and react
we're also going to be covering topics
like react.js with node
react with redux and understand what
react native is
we look at another detailed project
using react it will help you understand
the library better
after that we'll understand topics like
react hooks react router and then we'll
conclude the session by looking at some
of the commonly asked react interview
questions
now without further delay let's begin
in today's video we'll be learning all
about react.js so let's jump in and see
what's in store for us so we'll be
covering topics on what is react why
react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree now
let's see how this actually works react
creates a virtual dom that is the exact
copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on windows so without
further ado let's get started to set up
the react development environment we
need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website say
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
[Music]
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created
your application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file open folder go
to your desktop or the drive that you
saved your folder in first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components without delay let's begin and
look at what's in store for us so we'll
be touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order in pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the facebook home page the
entire ui can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or jsx file okay then let's go ahead
and build our first react application
using components all right so i've
opened my text editor that is vs code to
build my application also i suggest you
watch the react installation on windows
video to help you get started the video
briefly explains how to install node and
how to start building your first react
application in my case i've opened a
folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder i have
app.js now app.js is the main component
that gets rendered to the dom let me
show you that here in index.js you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the react dom so app.js
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
app.js is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibling let me save it and if you look
at the browser you'll have hello welcome
to simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple html tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create a first functional
component to do that i'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that i'll create a
file say functional component.js
all right so the first thing we have to
do is import react so i say import react
from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component
now you say return an h1 tag or i've
already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class the act dot component so
going ahead i say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
feature is used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export per
file and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
list components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional com let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it imported
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i say so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this let me give it
another name say class comp one and the
message that i want to display is hey
i'm another class all right so when i'm
exporting it i don't want default so let
me take it off and say export here all
right
in my app.js while importing it i want
to import both the classes so i'll
include them within curly braces here i
say class com comma class comp 1 and
then again i define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey i'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that i can
choose to import the classes that i want
to now say for example i do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nitty-gritties of it
because they're advanced topics but to
give you a brief insight higher order
components are basically functions that
take in a component and return a new
component the whole ideology behind
higher order components is to facilitate
the reusability of component logic okay
so let's see how this works let's go
back to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this benefit rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now see i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
zero so for that i'm going to use
another snippet called r const and here
this dot state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals this
dot
update click now update click is going
to be another method that we have to
define now so every time the button gets
clicked this method is called so let's
go ahead and define the function
so it is update click equals it's going
to be an arrow function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot account plus one okay and here
we say
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from
components click and let's define it
here so let's check our browser every
time we click on the button the value
gets incremented all right so let's go
ahead and create another component say
counter.js wherein every time the user
hovers the mouse on the button the count
value increases so let's go ahead and do
that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot state and here i change x to
come now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it higher order dot js okay
so i say import react
from react after that i say const
updated component equals
original component that's going to be an
arrow function again and within curly
braces i define my class that is class
say new component extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented to i say
this dot props dot name let me save it
let me do the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a read ender is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say purecom.js
so here i'm going to use a snippet rpce
that is going to create a pure component
class let me get rid of this export and
here in my div tag i'll display the text
say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regular component.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we are going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say
component did mount and here i say set
interval the first argument is going to
be an arrow function and the second will
be the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply done itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import pure
comp
from pure component and then i say
import regular comp from regular form.js
and here let's say regular comp name
equals this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot name now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
prop dot name and here i again say this
dot prop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply to set the state and
we're going to set the state for search
results to whatever is passed by the
system so the search results are going
to be returned as a callback and that's
what we store as an updated state now
coming to the add track method so let's
scroll up and we'll say add track and
this will take the track to be added
let's declare a temporary variable
called tracks equal to this dot the
current state of all the tracks that are
there in the playlist now if track start
find i'm going to call the find method
so if we are able to find which means
that the track is already there in the
playlist then we would not want to add
it if it's not there in the playlist
that's when we would want to go and add
it the triple equal to is an equality
operator that will check for both a
watch value match and a match on the
data type as well okay so if the track
is uh already saved to nothing if the
track is not safe just track the track
id because that is the track that will
uh have to be added if it's not if it's
already there then just return if it's
not there then we've got to go to this
variable called tracks we'll use the
javascript method called push and we
will push the current track into this
tracks array and then update the state
so we want to set the state of the
playlist tracks and this is how uh your
state management that we discussed in
detail is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state
dot playlist tracks those the set of
current tracks that we have and
let track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of javascript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the lambda operator and if the
current track dot id is
not equal to the track dot id which
means this particular track is not there
in the list okay so you need to remove
that and again i have a method called as
unshift which will actually get rid of
the track in the array and then we've
got to so we'll search whether that
track is existing in the tracks array if
it is then we simply want to remove it
if not we do nothing so we set the state
we need to update the state of the
playlist because the track has been
removed so the playlist tracks will have
to be updated with this tracks array
okay then we go for remove track search
that's the next method that also will
take a track as a parameter okay here we
are going to say let tracks which is
another temporary variable we'll give it
this current state of
search results and then we are going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot id not
be equal to the track dot id and then
this is where we would want to say this
dot
set state
and we'll pick up search results
and let's go and assign that to track so
that's the updated uh set of tracks
after making that change let's remove
this and correct it okay so that's fine
so the remove track uh
is now the remove track in the remove
track search is now in place let's add
the do these functions which actually
again takes track as a parameter and
here we'll say this dot add track okay
so it adds the track and then it removes
the track from the search criteria so
the search component which is managing
searching of the tracks it will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined
operation we want to execute then i've
got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and this dot set
state the playlist
name is what we need to update with the
name that is passed to this function
then we've got to save playlists so here
we let me create a constant variable
constants are variables whose values
will not frequently change we'll take
all the track uris dot state dot
playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot uri so
we actually want to go and uh now save
this on uh
spotify so that's the reason we'll
access
spotify's safe playlist method this dot
state dot playlist name comma track uris
and if that is successful we then go
into a callback so that's the callback
anonymous function where we're going to
say this dot
set date and the playlist
name that we want to create on spotify
will be called new playlist so that's
the custom name that i want to provide
and the playlist tracks
define that this closes here
okay so that's for the update on
spotify
now here is where
the render method is going to return the
html now this html is the view
and react simplifies this by having the
javascript and the html in the same
file so you can actually go and access
the variables you've declared in the
script directly in your html view and
synchronize and bind the data together
so it helps
from a maintainability perspective so
even though everything is in the same
file it's well classified and
differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'd say href is http localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom url name of
music or file so the h1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject our search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called search so
on search we just call we bind to a
method called this dot search then we'll
open up another div here we'll have
class name equal to app dash playlist
and if you remember that's exactly the
css
class name that we referred to in the
css file we have another component
called search results
that we're going to inject here
and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state dot search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if i
click on the add button for search
results
do these so it will add that new track
to the playlist by calling binding to
the 2ds function and it will remove it
from the search results text box then we
have another component called playlist
and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state dot
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current
component itself so whatever you put
into the app component or into the
respective component those values will
be then passed out here to these
individual functions okay so that's with
the playlist couple of things we'll have
to do is
if somebody changes the name of the
track so on name change is going to be
another custom event where we'll have to
call this dot update playlist name and
we also have remove functionality so to
remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on save equal to
this dot
save playlist okay so that's done and we
close this so we seem to be pretty much
on track the export
app will make this all of these
functions accessible across other
components it's very similar to the
public access specifiers etc that you
provide in other programming languages
so that's done we've created our app
component now let's create another
folder under components and we've got to
define all our various components here
this folder is going to be for the
search bar so we'll name it search bar
we'll add two files within it the search
bar dot css okay and another file that
we'll need here
is search bar
dot js
so that's in terms of the search bar
let's start with the css file so we'll
start with first styling search bar we
will say that the display should be flex
flex
direction should be column we want all
the items to be aligned at the center so
that's align item center then we'll add
up padding so padding top
is going to be
6.94 rem and
margin
bottom is going to be
6.33 rem all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
we'll add
for the input element we want the width
to be 287 pixels the padding to be 0.88
zero the border should be one pixel
solid white the border radius
will give a slight rounded edge uh to
give a web 3.0 look and feel so we'll
set up the border radius then we've got
uh margin bottom so we've got a bottom
margin that we want to add up then we
have color so let's add up the color c3f
so that's the color black then let's add
text alignment of
center and let's add up a font size of
one rem okay so that's how we've set
this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be
so if someone focuses so focus is the
got focus so if someone clicks inside so
the end user goes and clicks inside the
text box so we change the outline to
none okay and
so for the search bar we are interested
on input and if the input is
focused so that's the event that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to 8.11
rem the padding we are going to set up
to
0.77 rem and zero the border radius
we'll set it to 54 pixels so we get a
slightly uh well defined search button
with a nice little border let's also add
background color hash 1 db 954
that gives me a color then i've got
my text alignment let's set that to
center then we've got
a font family let's set up the font
family to
the same standard font 80
and it's a part of the sans serif family
then we'll set up the font size
to zero point eight three
rem correct this
and finally
we will need
transition so all of these are basic
css properties so that will add a slight
transitional effect with a delay of
that many milliseconds
so transition background color we've
provided what else let me scroll up
let's also provide a border here so
we'll remove in fact let's remove the
border we we would not want a border on
the button that would look odd so i'll
get rid of the border and color we'll
specify
as per our standard color that we've
been using okay so that's the color
we've specified and then i've got font
weight of 500. finally we'll take
the search button and on the search
button we will register for the hover
event so if someone takes their mouse
over the button that's the hover
event in that case if we hover around
the button we would want the background
color to change so it will appear to
have a slight little glow there a mouse
pointer moves over the button okay so
that's the opacity and
the rgb combination so that completes uh
the css file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and get the
code in for
our search bar component and that's
exactly what we are going to do next so
let's start with setting up the code for
the search file first thing let's go and
import react from
react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot
css file then we define our class
called search bar which extends
react dot component we define our
constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also define
the state
we just need one variable here which is
the term to search for in the search bar
and then let's say this dot
we'll define a function called handle
term change which is going to be equal
to this dot handle handle term change
dot
find so that's going to be the first
function then a function that will do
the searching for us
which is this dot search so that's the
search function and we'll have it bind
to this
then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this
so the functions are ready now let's go
for the first one which is handle term
change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot set state
and for the term
we will use the event keyword we will
get
the value that is there inside that text
box the moment the search term the user
has entered changes so the search
criteria changes we trap the updated
value then in the search function we
will update
the local property props dot on
search
okay so we'll access the on search and
pass it the updated term and then we got
the handle enter on which
we're also going to pass the system
define event keyword so if there's any
data flowing along with the event we are
interested in it in this case the data
is the key code that the user is
pressing and if it is 13 that indicates
that's the ascii key code for the enter
button so if the enter is hit then the
user is completed entering the search
criteria and we need to start searching
and that's where we write our render
method that's going to render the html
view and we return the complete view
here so that's the view now that we want
to return let's say tiff class name
equal to search bar then on the input
text box we will use placeholder equal
to enter song album
or artist that you want to search for on
change
on the on change event the moment the
term changes we connect that to handle
term change we already have an function
that manages that and the moment
keys are pressed and released so on key
up is where we would want to connect to
this dot handle enter okay and this is
place bracket that i'll have to put up
here so in the render function uh we're
going to return a value i shouldn't
forget to export the search bar okay so
that's uh what i want to export so we've
exported that okay so at the end of this
what we've done is we've written a
render method we've written our div tag
here is where we'll go and close
the div tag we've added an input and
here is where i'm going to add a button
provide a class name called search
button and the moment the end user
clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot
search and we close
the button back within the button tag
search so that
completes the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a constructor passing props to the super
class constructor we created
state we set it to a value of
term and null so the state currently we
defined as term then we said handle term
changes search and handle enter should
be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes
we defined search we defined and handle
enter we've also defined then we used
render render we said is going to return
to us the html that we've specified okay
we dumped all the html that we want this
component to return to us
so on change and on key up our
two functions that
or two events that we connected to where
we called handle term change and handle
enter then we added a button where we
registered for the click event and
connected it to this dot search so all
the three functions
that we
are actually written
so two things we have completed now uh
in the app class
okay if you look at the app class we've
actually defined a set of functions here
that deal with the playlist and adding
applications etc adding tracks delete
removing tracks
then we've created
the search bar okay so we saw that the
search bar also we have specified a set
of functions
and all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of javascript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core
concept when you're working with react
where you would actually have every
separate
block of
code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
components that we will need to build
and the next component is
the track component that will manage
individual tracks so a new folder a new
file called track.css
and
track.js
so that's going to manage
the tracks for us so let's start with
dot track we would say display is flex
align items
center border bottom one pixel solid
rgba 256
256
to 56 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes
when we write up the html view we'll add
a padding here of 0.5 we'll set up a
font size
of 1.05
set up a transition color of 0.20
s
border of 0 pixel and
a background color of rgb a
0 0 0 0 color ash
so that's the color that we continue to
use then we bring in track another class
track action and if we hover over this
class we want
the gb values
change to 265 265 2 6 5 5 is the last
paragraph so that's the hover
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with we'll add the flex
parameter first display flex
and
then flex
direction
is going to be column let's have justify
content set up as
center
and let's have height as
180 pixel so that's a track information
let's have another track information and
the h3 tags nested inside that for all
the h3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of 0.22
rdm finally let's have track information
and paragraph tag we'll have the font
size
of 0.83
rem and a font weight of 300 and a color
as well that we'll add so let's add up a
color here rgba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the css
and let's move to
the track and we'll move into the
javascript file so let's move into
so let me take what we added in the
search bar i'll go to the track.js
this will change to track dot css
okay the constructor this will change to
add track so add track change this to
add track this is
remove track change this to remove track
get rid of this and that's going to be
the add track function and here we're
going to say uh this dot props
so we'll modify this this dot
props
dot on add this dot props dot track and
then we have the remove track so that's
going to be the remove track function
this function is not required so this
dot prop start on
remove
and this is the track that we would want
to go and remove we'll add up another
function called
render action so this is going to be a
function uh that we are defining called
render action and in this we'll just
check if this dot props dot is
remove
if this dot props
dot is
removable so in that case
we would want to return so this is a
view
action method that we are adding which
is going to go and add this button with
a class called as track action that
we've already written the css for and
this button will actually get added
via this render action function and this
dot
remove track is
what it's going to map to
let's close this
this is going to point to this specific
function so that's uh the closing button
tag okay so the closing button tag is
what
we've added there and
the binding is what we have done to this
dot
remove track and we will terminate this
here
so now the render action uh let's also
have the return here and we just add up
the button and this is going to add
track so you can look at how the
component is completely dynamic uh in
nature so we have two buttons that are
going to be added this button with a
hyphen is going to remove the track this
button uh with a plus sign is going to
add the track and you can actually see
how simply it was done in a render
action function so the render action
function actually helped
with
checking that if uh
on the value of the props and if the
user
depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
the class name here is now going to be
track the class name for
uh the enclosing div inside it so let me
get rid of this
the class name for the enclosing div
here
is going to be track dash information
within it we'll add h3 we'll bind to
this dot props dot track dot name so the
name of the track is going to get bound
here then in the paragraph we will find
to this dot props
dot track dot artist
and
with some gap this dot props dot track
dot argo so that's what
we've data bound to
and then let me add an iframe an iframe
allows us to uh very easily inject some
content into the page within a small
embedded window the source parameter of
the frame is going to be https
open dot so here i'm connecting to the
spotify stream
spotify.com slash
embed slash track and close this so
that's the spotify stream that we're
going to connect to and this dot props
dot track dot id so that's the track id
the width is going to be 300 the height
parameter this the height parameter is
going to be 80 of the iframe and
the frame
order is going to be 0 and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow
encrypted media so if spotify has
encrypted media that also would be
embedded here and we can also have the
title set to preview so that's uh with
the iframe okay at the bottom is where
we would want to so this could be an
empty element and we can close it
right around here so we wouldn't need
this part and then here i'm just going
to say this dot
render action so we call the render
action method
which will actually give us plus minus
button to add and remove a
new element okay and that's
what we can actually go and add up there
so let's check now whether uh all that
we've done is good to go fine so
everything looks good uh in terms of the
track component now and
we have all of the functions in place
it's now time to jump into the
next component that we would require
after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
call this track list
and that's going to have
track list
css
and it's going to have
track list dot js
so that's the track list
component now which
we're going to go ahead and use
and the css we don't need much
so let's just say track
list
and we just provide a width of 100
okay that's all we need
in the css so let me add this in the css
file save this
and come to the js file now which is
going to have
the track list code that we will need to
add up so here again i'm going to say
import react
from react we'd also want to import
track list dot css
and
we
also want to go and get track because
this component is going to be made up of
a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll define
class track list which is going to go
and extend
react dot
component
we just need the render method here
because this just needs to go it does
not really have any state of itself it
simply goes and returns
a list of individual tracks
so this class name is going to be track
list
and we'll bind to this dot props dot
tracks dot
map create a temporary variable
and this will go and return
the track component
which is going to bind to individual
track data the key is going to be track
dot id so the key is going to be track
dot id
and on add on adding a new track we want
to bind to this dot properties dot and
we already have on ad defined so that's
what we'll connect to we add up my
base bracket here okay and
then we would also need
is
removal
equal to
this dot props dot is
removal and the on remove
will do this dot drop slot on remove so
that's for the track removal and
so we've got our track list
uh oh yes we'll have to go and
also close the tip tag correctly and
also we need to go and export so we'll
have to go and export
the track
list
so we've got one more component done
which is track lists and let's move on
to the next component now so we've got
app which is root we've got the search
file that takes care of entering the
search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a tracked list that
manages a set of track records so the
track is more relevant to the playlist
and then we've got the search results
also to manage once we search for some
set of tracks so we'll add a new folder
which manages search results
and this is going to have
search results dot css
and it's going to have
search results dot js
okay so we need a search results dot css
and js and here in the css file we'll
keep it simple for the search
results so we say search results we'll
set up the width of 50 percent we
set up the height of 950
pixels we'll say
overflow
y is
scroll we'll say padding is 0.88
rem background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of zero for pixels to
to
pixels
hash
and then uh let's add
a scroll bar so
webkit
and mozad are the constants specific to
mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants
and then we'll also add a media query
that if it goes with a max
with one zero two zero pixels
in that case dot search results
with is 90 percent
with a margin bottom of two
okay so
we're going to add the hyphen so it's
hyphen webkit scroll bar zero pixel
width
and we've set
transparent background so that's that's
about it with uh the css i need to get
to the uh js file now let's move to the
search results
js file
and that's where we will now have to go
and add up
the component code for search results
and let me take
pick this up from track list
add it up here this would be
search results and
we need the results will return to us a
list of tracks so we'll have to get uh
track list
this would be track list
and i'm just going to return class name
will also be search results so that's
the component and this is going to
export out search results so it's
accessible across other components then
we've got h2 with results let's go and
create
track list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props
dot search results and on the on add we
are going to bind to this dot props dot
on add so we already have that so that
uh basically completes
search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new books we'll
add up a new folder in components
and that's going to be playlist
and within that we will have a playlist
dot css
and
a playlist dot js
so that's our
playlist component now that
we're going to work with and the
playlist component is
uh we'll first set up
the css that we will need
to add up to the playlist and i'm just
going to
pick that up from my code snippet so
that's my playlist and let me get all of
that css here so that's uh just the css
for the playlist nothing to do with
react again pure css uh let me get uh
into the js file and that's where we
will need to go and add all of our
component code so again let me go to the
track.js
the track list rather
let me get this and add it
out here we'll make some small changes
this is going to be playlist
i need to import the track list
because the playlist is going to contain
a list of tracks
this is going to be
playlist and
let me
here this will be playlist and we'll
leave this
for later okay let me also get
the constructor in so we'll add up the
constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if i need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props
dot on name change that's when we'll say
event dot target
dot value so we get the updated playlist
name coming to the render we now need
the input
input
is going to be on change equal to
this dot
handle name change
the default
value we have already provided with a
hard coded value which is new playlist
so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got
track list so track list is
what i will add the tracks i'm going to
bind to this dot props dot
playlist
tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say
is
removal equal to
true and on remove
equal to we'll bind that to this dot
props
dot on remove finally we'll need a
button we will use
class name equal to playlist dash
save that's what we've added in the css
click equal to this dot props
dot on
save and here we're going to say save to
spotify so that's with the
playlist and yes we need to go and
export playlist and not track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick look up
in spotify so let's go to this website
called developer.spotify.com
and once once we sign in
and create an id it takes us to our
dashboard
that's where we can create a sample
application
the name of the application will be
musical file okay and uh we'll say that
we are building uh some kind of desktop
app for example for which we want to uh
connect this to and we'll also need to
provide
so we'll say next
refresh the dashboard so it's
asking me for a login so let me login
once more so moment i login that's going
to be description and i'll say maybe
this is why i need it i'll say no not
commercial integration
agree with the terms and conditions and
we will say submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now i can say edit settings
and
the redirect url here is what is
important
so it should accept connections from
http localhost 3000 that's the port on
which we will host our application okay
and we'll say save okay so that's uh now
there's a client id that is generated
here for my app which is unique so i'll
just copy that up let me come up to my
application under the source folder i'm
going to add a new folder
called util and under that a new file
called spotify.js
so we will start with
adding our code to the spotify.js file
that we've just created as a new file
within the newly created util folder the
first line of code is going to define a
client id variable that equates to the
client id that we will generate on
spotify so this is going to be the
spotify generated client id which is a
unique id associated for the developer
to connect to the spotify api and we
will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we'll create
is the redirect url or let's call it
redirect uri and that will equate to
localhost colon 3000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we'll equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot href dot
match
and we will say this is equal to access
token which will be equal to and we will
give a rejects expression to do a
pattern match ampersand so that we can
actually get into the url and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant
variable called expires in match
equal to window dot location dot href
dot match here we will read the expiry
information using another regex
expression from the url ampersand
asterisk so that's the second constant
variable we've created now we will say
if access token match and
expires in match in that case the access
token should be equal to access token
match of one then we create a variable
called
expires in equal to we'll do a typecast
to number and we will take the first
parameter from the expires in match
that's done then we will say
window.settimeout
and we are going to say access token
equal to comma expires in multiplied by
thousand then we will say window dot
history dot push state and we will say
access token we pass the second
parameter as null the last parameter as
slash
and close this and we will return access
token else
we will say const access
url equal to https
accounts.spotify.com
slash
authorize
client
underscore id equal to dollar client id
ampersand response type equal to token
ampersand scope equal to playlist dash
modify so we are actually building the
url that will now get generated so we'll
say modify dash public and redirect
url equal to dollar redirect uri so we
have constructed the url now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access url then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass
https
api dot
spotify.com slash
v1 slash
search question mark that's the query
string that we will add type equal to
track and ampersand g equal to dollar
and we will pass term comma as the
header information we will need to pass
the authorization where we will say that
the bearer is dollar access token dot
then response
return response dot json dot then so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so json response
and then we will say return response dot
json after that another then block so
we'll now say json response and if
not
jsonresponse dot tracks
in that case we will return
an empty array else
we will return
dot tracks dot items dot and we will
pass
we'll create track as a variable with a
lambda expression and we'll create a
temporary json object with id and that's
where we want to associate track dot id
that was returned as the search result
the name is going to be associated with
track dot name the artist is going to be
associated with track dot artists of
zero dot name the album is going to be
track dot album dot name and the uri we
will equate track dot url so that
completes uh this block will open the
next and we this will be the save
playlist which will take the name and
the track uris and here we will check if
not
name or not track uris dot len in that
case we simply return out of the code
and then we declare a constant variable
called access token which will be equal
to spotify dot get access token so we
get a reference to the access token we
then declare headers authorization
bearer is going to be dollar access
token and we'll create a user id and now
we will return the fetch result where we
will pass https
api dot spotify dot com slash v1 slash
me so that's the url comma headers will
be the header information then we call
the then function declare response as a
variable use the lambda expression and
access response dot json we use the then
block to declare json response
here we say user id equal to
jsonresponse.id and then we return
fetch
https
api dot
spotify dot com slash v1 slash users
slash dollar of user id slash playlist
so this is how we've constructed the
urls manually here we will say assign
headers to the headers variable we'll
assign method as post so the data is
sent as part of the body and not as part
of the url and as the body we will say
json.stringify to convert this parameter
name and then we will generate a
response variable to
response.json and then we'll create json
response with the lambda operation we'll
create a constant playlist id which is
equal to json response dot id we will
return fetch
https
api.spotify.com
v1 users
dollar user id slash playlist slash
dollar again we are constructing the url
so playlist id will be replaced here
then we will say tracks
and close this comma and here again we
will say headers would equate to the
headers
variable we constant headers and this
goes here okay everything fixed now so
here we're going to say headers should
equate to headers and
the method
is going to be post and the body is
going to be json dot stringify uris
track uris and we close this we close
this block we close this block and we
close this block so that completes our
code of course one more thing we have to
do which is export this class out so
export default spotify and that
completes the code for
the spotify.js
which is part of our utils class so
let's move on now to the next step so
uh here is uh the client id that we'll
have to exactly match so i'll copy this
client id and provide it here so that's
the client id uh that we actually need
and we could also store it
out here
so that's the uh client id and that's
the redirect url that we've also defined
there and we just create an access token
if your access token is true we return
access token so the access token is
something that we are going to do a
match from uh uh the moment we try and
connect with this particular url and you
can look here that this is the access
url that we are trying to connect with
okay with the client id and post fixed
with the redirect url right and then
i've got a simple search function which
returns an observable so we try to fetch
data using the search term that we
provided okay we try to fetch data using
the search term provided if we are
successful we get a response of the data
and accordingly we'll iterate over the
json response and get a list of tracks
out of it and do a mapping of this json
object to the track id name artist
information album name etc and here uh
just like a data access layer very
similar to a data access layer we've got
a save function which will save this
data to spotify as well so i've got a
save playlist and i've got search so
these are the two functions which will
go and connect to the spotify service by
using this client id and it will allow
me to
access that information in terms of
returning a stream of json data and will
then allow me to
go ahead and push that json data into
our application so now we
actually need to start up the
application so i'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and bring
out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens powershell from
which you can actually fire your
commands so i'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so i
need to grant access
to that port 3000 let's give it time to
run and that's the app now that
you can actually see here so this is
the search bar that we actually had okay
then we had the results we had the
playlist now the results is going to
consist of
a set of
tracks which are maintained by the track
list and then you can take individual
tracks with the plus and minus button
and add them into the playlist okay so
that's how
it's typically going to work okay so as
you can view here
i'm just going to search for an artist
and we'll click on the search button it
goes to spotify tries to connect there
and says
that i need to agree to the terms and
conditions
and i've just agreed to that so the very
fact that it actually uh gave us uh a
confirmation link uh the moment we tried
to connect and execute our application
uh that's proof enough that it actually
went and
it to the
service there and try to return a value
to us so this is what we did we just
added an artist we said search
and you can see now it's successfully
connected i've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are
buttons that got added onto this list of
tracks dynamically the moment the search
results returned a value
so i can click on this plus sign and you
can see that the track gets added to the
playlist okay as in when i click here so
i've added a couple of tracks
uh if i go back to my dashboard of my
musical file application and that i've
created here in the developers portal of
spotify on
developers.spotify.com it's blank so now
i'm going to click on save to spotify
okay and that clears the playlist
so let me come here
and
now when i come out here we saw that it
actually got
successfully connected out here now i'll
have to log in to so this was the
development app that we actually created
on the developers portal of spotify now
we will go to spotify.com
so i'll just go to the spotify website
and it says do you want to launch the
web player and all that so let me click
on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that i'd actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so i can go here and
i can delete this playlist and say i
want to delete it okay so there's no
playlist now i'll go back here
i'll add two tracks and i'll say save to
spotify so that's how you actually saw
that the new playlist you can see the
new playlist has come back here okay and
that's the playlist the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that
got created and we deleted it but it
still got created again and that
indicates the connectivity uh that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks then we created the search
results which will generate a list of
results which further contains a track
list and this is the embedded iframe
which gave us the response which is
scrollable here and you can see that the
iframes we created allowed us to scroll
this
with this embedded web page inside the
iframe container so with that
i hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
request to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be implemented on
the page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and re-testing the entire
application as a whole in this session
we'll be comparing the three cutting
edge ui development technologies that is
react.js angular and vue we learn about
the key differences that make them so
distinct all of these technology stacks
have been replacing pure server-side
technologies and we've slowly progressed
from server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while vue deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balanced
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dorm
updation is time consuming risky and
error-prone vue also ensures faster and
bug-free performance now let's talk
about data binding the core reason why
we would use single page applications
now consider a scenario where you log
into an e-commerce website as the user
one then you should be able to see the
items in your shopping cart while user
two would be seeing different items in
their shopping carts and so on so
identifying the user and retrieving data
corresponding to that specific user is
facilitated using the help of data
binding data binding is a process that
allows an internet user to manipulate
web page elements using a web browser
now it is used in interactive components
such as calculators tutorials games etc
now react supports one way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while vue also uses
a similar two-way data binding in react
every time the model state updates the
view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now view typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for vue according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support welcome to this
session on how to connect react.js with
node.js and in this session uh we are
actually going to look at
how do we connect react.js with node.js
so a very warm welcome to this session
on react.js connectivity with node.js
and in this session we are going to
focus on how do we connect our react.js
application with the node.js platform so
we are going to dive into creating a
hands-on demo which will have two parts
to it we would have the client
application that we will first create as
a react application we will then create
an expressjs application with node.js
and we will then try to connect both of
those applications together so
express.js is a rapid application
development framework that allows us to
create a web application very quickly on
the node.js platform and we'll use it to
create a custom api and then connect
that endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and let's start with creating our client
and node express applications and see
how to set them up and then get them
connected to each other let's start with
our hands-on demo and we will first go
to the node.js website nodejs.org we can
download the lts version which is a
stable version of node.js moment i click
on this it will prompt me for a download
it will download the msi file and then
all i need to do is double click on it
keep clicking on the next button and
install that would install node.js for
us next we'll open our editor you can
use any editor of your choice so i'm
going to use
an editor called
visual studio code and let's open up the
terminal here and i also have the
command prompt open where i've navigated
to a folder that i've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and
we will use npx to go and create a react
application called client so while we
give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it
within our editor so we'll give it time
so that the installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we have seen here that the installation
is now completed and let's uh go and
open up this project so i will say file
and open folder and
let me pick up that folder and we will
open this application called client so
that's my client app let's fire up the
terminal so
okay so that has launched the terminal
for us
and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us
a startup page the sample uh default
startup page for the first client
application uh and this is going to work
as a client we'll now go and try to
create
the backend
application which is going to be another
application that we will set up and to
create that
let's say npx
express
generator api okay so this will create
an express application on node.js called
api and let's give it some time for
installation okay so that's done clear
this screen we'll come out here we'll
open another instance of the editor
we'll say open folder and that's the api
application we'll say select folder and
the api application is opened let's go
to the terminal now in the terminal we
will attempt to install all of the
packages that are required that would be
logged in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be a listed
uh so you can see we have a list of uh
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed
correctly and we'll fire that once more
that's done so npm install has installed
all of the packages required and let me
terminate this run by pressing a control
c so this terminates uh the client
application that was executing and now
we will say npm start so that this
application executes and let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the api application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test api dot js
here we will say variable express
equal to require express
and here we'll say variable router equal
to express dot
router and here we will say
router dot get will open this
so that's the default route route route
is going to be slash for which we'll add
a callback function which will take the
request and the response parameter and
next pointer in case there is another
function to call post that and here we
will just send a simple message saying
api is working okay a simple message
sent out for the root default route and
we'll have to export this so we'll say
module dot exports equal to router all
right so that's uh done let's go to the
app.js file and here let us import that
so here is where we will import this
by saying app.use we want to use the
test api file and that is
test api router and this is exactly the
same variable name that we will declare
here which will be equal to require and
we are going to say routes
test api all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test api is going to
be the url to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test api and there we have a
message which says that the api is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application
let's go to the app.js file okay this is
the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here
we will declare a class app which
extends so that creates a new module so
it extends react.component
and here we have constructor we will
accept the props here i would pass props
to the superclass
constructor and
set the state to api response
currently it just has an empty value
next we'll add up a new function called
call api which will generate a call to
that api url which was http localhost
9000 was the port and test api was the
url once this is called we will then
call the then function declare response
generate a call to response.txt and then
we will again say this dot set state api
response is going to be equal to the
response that comes in from that url
which is nothing but a string which says
api is working another function called
component will mount so the moment the
component is initialized on the screen
and loaded we will generate a call to
this function we created called call api
then comes
the render function in the render
function we would go and return a div
class name as app this would be app
header the standard logo after which
in the paragraph we wouldn't need the
link here right after the header we'll
add a paragraph where we will print this
dot state and the variable we created
called api response and we will data
bind to that so that largely completes
uh the return so we simply create this
application uh that's the react
application that will talk to this api
that is and this uh url that is hosted
on node communicate with it get a simple
string as a response print that string
inside this
react application so once that's done
we have the component wheel mount which
is a life cycle method here it's a life
cycle event that gets triggered the
moment the component loads and that's
when
we have actually gone and executed the
call api custom function let's go to the
api application we'll terminate the
execution here there's one more step
that we'll have to perform which is
cross origin
resource sharing which means that to
allow the react application to
communicate from another hosted domain
to this particular domain server we will
actually have to enable cross origin
scripting and sharing otherwise it will
block the request coming from another
application so for that we'll have to
install globally cross origin module and
dash dash save indicates that it's going
to do a global install for all
applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this
and we'll clear the screen let's go to
the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use core so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this
particular api and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new library package that we
just installed which is quartz so looks
good and now let's
fire up this application with an npm
start let's also fire up client with an
npm start and now when i go and
try looking for localhost 3000 which is
the react application the react
application should go and talk to the
api that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
i go and ping that api separately which
is localhost
9000 test api you can see this is a
standard message so here i've directly
ping the api that's hosted in node.js
now we are consuming it through the
react.js application and if you scroll
down you can see the message returned
from node.js into react saying the api
is working properly so the practical
impact of this is to actually host
restful services etc on node as a server
and you can go and consume the data that
is returned there could be in string
text or json format directly into the
react.js acting as a client application
today we're going to cover react with
redux
so with our session today we're going to
go through it's going to cover why you'd
want to use redux when you're building a
react solution
what redux is what are the core
principles of redux and what are those
pillars that drive what you're doing
redux and then finally what are the pros
and cons of redux and after we've gone
through the powerpoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using uh redux so you
can actually see how this would all look
so why would you use redux well the
reason why you want to use redux is that
redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object
and redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state for an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so
the state could be modified by actions
in your network uh they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser and the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties
and then with redux it actually takes in
and actually will create a
you know take a a large application that
you could create with app with a react
and breaks it down to several components
instead of having this massive number of
states you have to manage and so every
time that you you know an application
would then switch from a current with a
react you'd actually be then changing
the state and this is a a really big
problem because when you're like doing
that switching back and forth there is
the potential for applications to be
re-rendered which reduces the efficiency
of your application and so this is why
redux was introduced
so you know what is redux so redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
stake container for your javascript
applications they allow you to run your
applications in multiple different
environments so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
or one of the key elements that i like
about redux is that it's really easy to
test and so with redux you're able to
manage the state of your tool uh you can
actually use it to work with any
javascript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
the application can be described to the
store by the user and then it notifies
any modifications made to the state of
that application so let's jump into the
key principles of redux and there's
three key areas i want to focus in so
the first one is that redux provides a
single source of truth
and that source of truth is uh being
able to store the state of your whole
application in an object tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect uh
components of your application
also enables you to be able to persist
your app state for development and
improve faster development cycles
the second principle is a state is read
only and this way you're able to
describe more effectively what's
happening because it is read-only and
this ensures that no events like network
callbacks uh would uh
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application and
that object actions are become then just
plain objects and then finally changes
are made with pure functions and so what
do we mean by this so we can actually
take actions and transform the state
tree
with pure reducers and we'll go into a
demo later on to show you this
but a reducer is essentially a function
that accepts an accumulation value and
then it takes back and returns that as a
new accumulation and this allows you to
have a single source of truth value the
user can return the new state objects
instead of mutating to previous state
uh the user can
start with a single reducing as the app
grows it can then split off into smaller
reduces
and then finally the reducers just
become functions so let's talk about the
pillars of redux
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
and there are four key
states there's get state which turns the
current c to the store and when we
actually run the demo later on you'll be
able to see that we'll be able to open
up our terminal window and be able to
get the state store from our terminal
window uh the second state is dispatch
and this is a an action it's the only
way to update the application state and
here we have a action on a button change
to actually change the state of the
application
and then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe
and these are our ways in which you can
actually change the listener to the
state
so an action is a plain object that
represents an intention to change the
state so with actions you have payloads
of information that send data back and
forth to your application store
so you can send any kind of data
that can go back and forth and that
actions must also have been a type field
that indicates the type of action that
has been performed and finally with
reducers reducers are
specified how the application state
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application state change
they are a reducer is a function that
accepts the current state and an action
and then returns a new state with the
action performed and then finally you
can use combined reducers utility which
can then combine reduces in an app into
a single a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with redux is that
redux provides a single source of truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
this then leads to having a predictable
and strict outcome redux is more
stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing redux
code this makes it also then
easier for the initial render which
allows you to make out your solution
really optimized as an experience and
then finally developers can track
everything that's going on inside the
app in real time the cons
so
one of the big cons is there's no
encapsulation so you're using redux to
test out the code and the writing of
your code
but the component cells can access data
and they there is potential for security
issues
you do have to use boilerplate code so
this kind of takes us back to the
structured code format it is um strict
in its um setup and it is memory
intensive so with that let's go in and
look at a demo of using redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in windows mac os and
linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want
i encourage you to go with the latest
lts version it's the latest stable
version now there are other versions you
can use but that's one you would want to
use i already have it installed so i
just want to show you how that looks so
i'm just going to go in and put
node dash dash version it's going to
give me the version number so that shows
it's installed and we'll also use npm
which is node package manager because
we'll be using that validate that it's
installed by doing node mpm
version so okay so looking good and
we're going to go ahead and create a
folder um on our desktop um normally you
wouldn't put
a project folder on your desktop but you
know this is just for an experiment so
we're going to call this one
redux react it's going to be taking a
react project and we're going to show
what it looks like as a standard project
and then what it will look like
as a project that's being
taken through redux
so let's just move our cursor to the
correct folder
and so we're going to go to cd redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
uh you use terminal on mac os
so let's just type in mpx and that's for
our redax and we're going to do create
dash react dash app so we're going to
create a default react app and then
we'll also install redux dash app
and these are the two
components that we need to be able to
build out our solution one is react and
it's react.js
and the second is redux and we hit
return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
just give that a moment
and so it's installing the different
packages react react dom
react scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so we
use visual studio code to do most of our
work here vs code
is open source solution for scripting
and it's available on all leading
platforms uh it is from microsoft but it
is open source and
there's just a ton of stuff here but
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to open up the folder we just created on
our desktop
and so here is redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder which is
going to get rid of the welcome screen
we don't need that anymore uh you'll see
there's some commands we use we do uh
control plus
um i'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
not an exclamation point
so you'll see that in our project folder
we have all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files product files
is just the application itself so over
here on the index.html you see the index
file there and we're going to actually
show what this looks like inside
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now
we're going to create a very simple
application here and the application is
going to look exactly the same in both
um
just standard react and redux react it's
the optimization that's going to be
improved so we just did mpm dash and
start it's going to take us to local
host call on 3000 give it a moment and
then we should get our
floating
uh
logo showing that the application's up
and running up there we are
we can go ahead and head and edit app.js
to
create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into app.js
and we are going to create an
application called
new comp
dot js and we actually have some code
that we've already created that you can
download as part of this application
um so but we're just going to type in
here import react
and then component
from
[Music]
react
so i'm going to pull in our react
library
and we also import
connect
from
react
redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
let's
terminate the batch job yes
and then rerun
npm
install
dash dash save
react
dash redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show how you can
optimize your solution with redux for
the
using the store and reduces in redux
again
the solution is going to look exactly
the same what's going to change is the
performance of the solution
and this is what redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in and type in class
new comp
extends component
and then we're just going to select our
constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this
state
equals
i have a message here
subscribe
to simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to apply some
styles
let's just make the
apply some font style
make the italics
then we're going to
make the color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
i'm sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
and we want to rent that
on the screen
we just have some basic
html for where we're going to place
everything we use div tag
for our
app again we're going to keep this
really simple
and we're going to call we'll reference
this styles for
this h3 tag
and so our message is going to be
subscribe to simply learn
this will be created dynamically we use
our style
i'm going to add in a button
click
action
subscribe
and don't change too many s's
i'll save that
see now let's run
a script
you're going to have js
and we're going to actually import that
into our app.js script
get rid of this
and then
and we'll extend
and news corp js
component into here
player in
font style here
and
render this correctly
and i'll pull in the text
and styles
again it's pretty simple little
application
not playing from newscop
so we'll actually have
a welcome screen a welcome line and then
pulling the two lines of code
all right let's
run
that npm start
and here we go
refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard state object
and
see now oh yeah this is good now we
actually can show you that uh we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
because newport news
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we
uh have a correct export feature here so
that the image that the
everything can be exported effectively
import we also need to have an export
all right let's run that again
okay should take care of our
problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard state
object of subscribe to simply line and
hit subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing
okay so let's kind of go in and modify
this now so it goes from being a
standard state object to one that uses
store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job
and essentially reset everything
and what we're going to do now is
install redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install redux
all right so we have redux installed
that's good
and now we want to start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
here's our react dom
now we're going to add in
contour
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and
we're gonna
pull in
strict mode
okay juicer's not too fine let's go
ahead and define that
so
we're going to come over
to our new comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going
to
take out the one class file that we just
created
and
just kind of stripping it down here
now let's go in
and
let's map our state
to
props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state dot message
and then
construct map dispatcher props
and this is going to be our dispatch
and we're going to be in
return
and we have our button
change
and for dispatch
we'll type in what the message is
now we have message change
let's turn from the button okay
so we'll pass the value over
all
right and now we actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
i'm going to do map state props
and map
dispatch props
all right now we're going to go in and
it's going to be for our new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here
so serve to button change we're going to
do props dot button change
otherwise we won't be able to find in
our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our redux
store
and we're going to call the store
reducer.js
and
const
initial state equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to simply then
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and constant new state
and
it's going to be
an if action
dot type
i'm gonna change the message
it's unused comp
so that's the
action there pull that
so it's identical
and then
new state dot message
equals
thank you for subscribing so
we have the default and now we have the
new message
yeah this might seem like extra work but
actually makes your
whole application much more efficient
and export default
reducer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start and see what happens
and our web browser should load up
oh we have an error
that's good so now we're learning stuff
so this is again this is all part of
your standard coding is just hunting
down errors in your code so let's go to
index.js
and
we're going to pull in here so we have
reduce and this should actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
let's
rerun a
file
and do we want to move our file let's
just go ahead and move the store
i'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be providing make
sure our provider store
[Music]
is referenced correctly
okay let's rewrite our application
and
there we are
so let's go back through
our application is running much faster
now
we're able to manage our changes and our
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
solutions how this become useful and you
can start using the different components
you create
for your whole solution
and that's our demo
hi guys welcome to this video on react
native
if you wish to build mobile applications
and are confused as to which tool to use
then you're in the right place
this video on react native will explain
what react native is and guide you
through it
but wait before beginning if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already then
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so here's what you'll be learning in
this session
first we'll understand what exactly
react native is
then we look at why react native is
being so widely used off lately
moving ahead we look at the differences
between react native applications and
platform specific applications
after understanding why react native is
used we'll understand some of the
prerequisites for building applications
using react native
then we'll understand react native
fundamentals like view state props and
style
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at some of the industry trends
of react native
so let's begin
what exactly is react native
now react native is a framework that
combines the best parts of native
development with react to build user
interfaces
these applications that are developed
using react native are downloadable on
google play store and apple store plus
because most of the code you write can
be shared between platforms react native
offers a wide collection of ui kits and
makes it easy to simultaneously develop
for both android and ios devices
but you must be wondering why is react
native used
so let's look at some of the reasons why
react native is used
first up is cross platform
cross platform means that the
applications can easily be run on
microsoft windows linux and mac os
so you can build your code base once and
then run it on any platform as opposed
to software built natively for a
specific platform next up is performance
now the react native apps are compiled
into natively written code which enables
it to not only work on both the
operating systems but also functions the
same way on both the platforms with no
lags at all
moving ahead there's quicker development
now react native offers excellent
developer experience it provides strong
developer and debugging tools with
meaningful error messages so working
with this tool becomes very easy
a large developer community now there
are several github repositories on react
native and groups on facebook
stack overflow is an excellent website
with several developers interacting
about issues on a regular basis
next up is wider audience
now since react native applications run
on both ios and android devices there's
a huge user base
and lastly react native has a great
career scope
considering the pace at which the
framework took over the market and its
simple approach to resolving development
problems the future of react native
looks more promising than ever
so these were some of the reasons why
react native is being widely adopted
so now let's go ahead and look at some
of the differences between react native
applications and platform-specific
applications
as discussed earlier react applications
work on multiple platforms while in the
case of platform-specific applications
as the name suggests these applications
are built for the specific platform only
developers have a stronger web
development background while in the case
of platform-specific apps they have a
very strong platform's language
background
in this case when you consider ios
developers have a very strong hold of
swift which is a programming language
used to develop ios applications and
talking about android developers have a
very strong hold on java
when it comes to react native it has a
faster build time and is less suitable
for complex applications
comparatively platform specific
applications have a slower build time
and are suitable for complex
applications
react native is best for small
development teams with limited resources
while in the case of platform specific
applications it is best used by
experienced developers who have adequate
experience in building mobile apps
so now that you know what exactly is the
difference between react native and
platform specific applications let's
look at some of the prerequisites for
building apps using react native
first up you should have a strong hold
in programming concepts like functions
objects arrays and to lesser extent
classes
now understanding javascript and all the
javascript libraries and frameworks is
crucial
and lastly you need to be familiar with
html and css concepts so as long as you
have a strong hold of these then react
native development becomes very easy
so now that you know what react native
is you've understood why it's being used
some of the prerequisites for react
native let's look at the basic concepts
like view state props and styling in
react native
let's begin with view
now view is the most fundamental
component of building a ui
it is a container that supports layout
with flexbox style some touch handling
and accessibility controls
now view maps directly to the native
view
equivalent on whatever platform react
native is running on so here you can see
there's a simple code snippet and the
output for it so as you can see there's
a hello world message in a render method
and the same is being rendered and the
view component here is being imported
from react native
now view as mentioned earlier acts as a
container with support for flexbox
layout and other styles
so flexbox is designed to provide a
consistent layout on different screen
sizes
moving on to state now there are two
types of data that control a component
one is props and the other one is state
now props are generally set by the
parent and are fixed throughout the
lifetime of a component
but for data that is going to change we
make use of state
so here you can see you have made use of
the this dot stay dot my state in my
render method you can also use the set
state method when you want to change it
moving on let's look at props
most components can be customized when
they are created with different
parameters these created parameters are
called props short for properties now
props are passed from one container to
another as a way of passing data between
them
so here using the name as a prop
lets us customize the message in the
component so we can reuse our component
for each of our tv shows here
so this is how you can use props in our
component
lastly talking about style react native
uses the conventional javascript
styling for components so the style
names and values are similar to how css
works
now to style we either use inline style
or style sheet
so you can see here we've provided
inline styling with a background color
a color and a font size and accordingly
the output is displayed
moving ahead to our last and final
section
let's look at the industry trends today
talking about salaries the average
salary of a react native developer in
india is around 6 lakh indian rupees per
annum
and the salary of a react native
developer in the us is around 96 000 us
dollars per annum now as you can see
react native has a higher growth
trajectory compared to other frameworks
as a result is being readily deployed by
many companies
applications like facebook instagram
netflix
pinterest uber uber eats among others
are developed using react native welcome
to this session on react native versus
flutter in this session we would look at
identifying some of the differences
between the react native and flutter
frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at key aspects to
identify differences between both the
frameworks predominantly on the language
front the ui aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these frameworks along with the
industry trends
in terms of the industry adoption for
both these platforms the core objective
of the session would be that at the end
you should be able to decide and make an
informed decision as to which framework
is the best among those available let's
start from a language perspective now if
you look at react react is basically
completely written and built in
javascript using the react.js api on the
other hand if you look at flutter it is
basically written in a very new language
called as start and we do not have uh
too many developers that are skilled on
dart however uh every browser and every
platform being shipped with
an in-built javascript execution
environment that makes javascript
platform the language of choice
for developers so every browser today or
every browser manufacturer
would have inbuilt support for executing
javascript programs similarly most
popular platforms mobility platforms
like android and ios have default
support for executing javascript
programs and that's the reason when you
compare this with flutter flutter uses
start which is predominantly a newer
language and we really do not have too
many developers who are skilled on this
so that really is the selling point uh
and the usp of react native because when
you work with react native uh you really
do not have to relearn a lot you don't
have a sharp learning curve most of the
javascript developers who are working
with memes tag already working with html
css
and dhtml can easily align to this that
as we have discussed
is pretty new in the industry and would
not have that much of penetration in the
developer community from a ui
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on native
components for the android and the ios
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary
set of widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement
third-party widgets and ui frameworks as
well now this is really what allows you
to pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use kendo ui or a set of
generic controls or any other
third-party ui framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the ui components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically
is built and uses javascript out of the
box and that's the reason when you want
to write any code in javascript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flutter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined
documentation repository and it allows
developers to go through it in a very
simple manner so it's all structured
it's all organized unlike what you see
on react native because in react native
it actually since react native is an
open ecosystem and allows you to
implement third party widgets and you
can do a lot of configuration and plug
and play and that's the reason uh the
documentation also is not very strong
well organized and impactful and that's
the reason uh most developers would find
it a little challenging to go through
the react native documentation when you
compare that to the documentation
available in terms of flutter popularity
is always a key when working with
platforms and that should be a crucial
decision maker because when it comes to
open source technologies and you're
stuck somewhere you obviously go to the
commit to the community to go and find
out how best you can solution the
problem now flutter being relatively a
new entrant into the market it does not
have a lot of developer penetration and
that's the reason the popularity in the
community is not very strong react
native being there for a while now it's
been around for some time and that's the
reason uh it's pretty popular among
developers also since uh it uses
javascript it's a natural transition and
a progression path for those who are
working with html5 css building web
applications or have been building
hybrid mobile apps find it very easy to
migrate to this because flutter requires
you to learn a new programming language
which is start and that is one more
reason why the popularity of this is
much much better on the react native
front as compared to flutter again if
you look at google trends uh you could
actually look at both of the lines here
the red line indicating flutter it
started on a very positive note and then
there was a plateau and then suddenly a
spike react native has been much more
steady in terms of its growth and
ultimately if you look at it now both of
them seem to be trending at par with
each other so the community support as
we were speaking about if you look at
stack overflow which is one of the most
popular websites to go for any kind of
developer
trends and movements and for a q a that
most developers would have you can
actually look at the number of questions
here and
also react native is part of
github as it's open source it was
released in 2015 and uh it's because of
the huge community support that it
becomes
easier to implement this you have a lot
of confidence as a developer when you
start building on this stack
because if you're stuck somewhere you
will have a lot of help available on the
way on the other hand if you compare
that with flutter you can look at the
question count here on stack overflow
and this being a new entrant in the
market uh it has a smaller footprint on
the community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases uh there again you would see
that react native does a much better job
as compared to flutter so the industry
tents are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if
we would need to make a decision in
terms of our careers the technology that
we are learning what is the growth
aspect what is the industry adoption and
how we could really move ahead on our
career graphs in terms of the
opportunities market the job market etc
so again getting back to stack overflow
which is the benchmark for understanding
technology trends in ide sphere and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that uh both
these technologies uh have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better a lot of organizations
implementing this clutter has been a new
entrant and hence uh
slightly fewer opportunities as the
penetration still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and
from a developer skills perspective so
these are some of the big names that are
using react native in their
implementations right from facebook to
pinterest to wix skype tesla insta
bloomberg you can actually look at
the implementation across industry which
is absolutely crucial when you're
learning something new because when you
want to join a large logo obviously if
there are a lot of logos using this that
enhances the credibility of your to your
learning puts a justification to why you
would want to learn this technology
flutter on the other hand associated
with big names like google sonos alibaba
the largest retailer out there from a
conclusion perspective if we were to
conclude on what we've discussed from a
language perspective obviously we said
react is much more popular since it is a
natural progression for developers to
work on javascript and move to this as
compared to dart which is relatively a
new language from a ui perspective the
open source plug-and-play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party ui platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt
widgets to implement the performance
aspect we discussed because of the
bridge from the code that you write to
the native component access exists in
react and is isolated and not any longer
required in flatter and hence the
performance is impacted because of the
additional layer in between the
documentation much much better in
flutter because it's a closed ecosystem
and they can control what you can use
react native being open-ended it really
has a lot of third-party integration you
can do and hence the documentation is
not really well organized the popularity
perspective react native much more
popular among html5 css three mer mean
stack developers since it's all
javascript flutter needs you to learn
new skills and you need to spend
additional time for that from a
community support react native has been
there for a longer time as compared to
flutter and hence has a stronger
community support as compared to flutter
and that translates into better job
prospects in the industry for react
native as compared to flutter so if we
were to give it a score react scores
much better with a total score of 5
leaving flutter with a total score of 2.
so i hope we were able to understand the
differences between the react native and
flutter and this will help you make
better decisions with planning your
career and deciding which technology you
should latch on to
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy um but the
whole thing is going to be created with
react and so be using javascript to be
installing react and installing the
various components such as node.js and
the different npm solutions that we need
so as you can see the calculator works
just fine and now let's go ahead and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows mac os and also
linux installers you can also download
the original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it um so we're just going
to go ahead and install the windows
version i already have installed so you
have to download it again you also want
to make sure that you have the latest
version of node.js installed now with
that node package manager so we're just
going to open up our terminal window and
validate which version that we have
running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node
version and it'll tell us which version
and which means that's installed and
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to uh
do that and we're gonna also now create
a react app so we're going to do install
and then it's going to be create dash
react dash app that's the command to
create a new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put
mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and
that will take a few minutes just to
install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be disabled
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel of the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have
our new folder right there
on our desktop um but we're actually
going to go now into visual studio and
if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to work with the
node.js in visual studio code
because i can run terminal window right
there so i'm going to open up the folder
that we just created that's
called calculator i and we open up the
whole folder and not a file but the
whole folder and here's our folder on
the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default
uh element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div with the id of root that's
going to reference um some
class files that we create and so the
app.js file has the application code
that we're going to be modifying in a
little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the id
element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so we're constantly referencing and
cross
our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
uh npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's have localhost and
everything running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react.js
application nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some of our code so uh let's
see now yep everything's running where
we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus c and actually stop
the outboy
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go
site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in
and
we're going to just restart
our application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see
our default
react app
coming up on port 3001
and there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment
we'll put in default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
i'm going to call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components
layout you need so we have the dot
because we have to go up one folder
that's the command for that so dot op1
folder components folder layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
and we do this using css
then we're going to import
react
from
react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css it's going to be a css file that
we're going to create
so we're gonna have to type that in
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so
here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up
correctly so we'll go to our web page
now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so
let's see now
[Music]
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
you run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in
a
hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this
div so that actually starts
pulling in the application
and
put in the class name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay
so you
need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a
css file that we'll use to create these
elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
but
as bottom line is that the calculator
really is
a bunch of form elements
um such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
um that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so
why not use the the same bottom elements
which consistently work from browser to
and then just simply
update the look and feel of them with
some css so that
they they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command
um this is some basic javascript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do
another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's delete
now we have an unclick event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here
make sure everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just gonna copy everything over just
make it a little bit easier ourselves
and then we're just going to find pin
the numbers
7 8
9
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep
going through making all the changes
here so we actually fill out all the
different elements
so as you can see most of this
isn't really complex it's
just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen start seeing
all the different elements
okay i can get it
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to
our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
so now
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
and so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just gonna
pull those over
um
we can
if you want to um and have us do a more
detailed video on how to
create csc css files and
you know we'll certainly do that but i
think most you probably know how to do
this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the border color et cetera et
cetera
and so i'm going to do that here we have
our
buttons
for our ab
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css and we just
have basic buttons
we have the css link back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
default logo
so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets from the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
then we'll create another folder we'll
call this one images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
just reference that in our image
reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder
and under assets we go to amg which we
have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so we'll remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is
from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width
and we have to know it's 150 pixels and
the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
css
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling and my css folder
um but uh in this instance because we're
just putting up a solution i want you to
be able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are i have our
simplyland logo
okay so now we need to have the
results screen make sure that looks
correct
okay
and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output of that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
uh this is going to be our component the
users will put their
results into
and approach row
put our instructions here so we're going
to like export
default
output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct our solution
now we're going to update the output
row.js file
and
we're going to
add in our return value
so put it div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field
that will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here
and
that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output row.css
we're going to add in our specific css
for
this output row
[Music]
and as you can see we're just using
all of our standard html5
skill sets here
and
let's go over to our
style it
will pull in our
props dot text size
and then the default um
value
and so this is going to align with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly as we're tapping on the
buttons
and so this will
play in our output row
and the value will be
[Music]
we bring our text size for output flow
here
we're just gonna put some
sample css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output i'm going to
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be
the calculation broken out as we've
written it and the bottom row will be
the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have
some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you can see they're referring to a
font asset we actually have the font in
there we have to
pull that font over and
it's just a ttf font true type font
uh you can use and any of the
internet fonts as well google has a
massive library
of fonts
and there we are
i'm going to change the size of our font
so that the second row the text is a
little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so connect
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
and for the result
the you state
the initially state will be just blank
there we are
this is what you'd expect to see
so the results
um are blank and this is just when you
run the app for the very first time
okay so going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event when we click on
any of the buttons
we want to take the value of the button
and
so this
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and
we're just going to put together our
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far
we've put most of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base react application putting
together the different files and folder
structure
um making sure we have the correct
assets such as
images
fonts
uh
css files
um laying out our core structure in html
form elements
and now um the part that we're doing at
the end here
is putting together the script
that will actually write
that actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are lots of
javascript calculators on the internet
so you can actually take any of those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
and there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error a result
we don't expect to see that
we'll just keep putting together our
code here
[Music]
so our different results
so depending on
which commands you use so for instance
it's the equal sign
and
you have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll capture our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
[Music]
if there are any error messages
so if the value is
c from the button so if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and
if the value
equals
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
[Music]
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard
javascript control
so hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
that as the value
all right
allows us to test out our application
all looking good so far
okay
i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have
the
display and the input
it's all coming from
here our output class
put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands or your variables lining
up
correctly
eliminate those
now we'll make sure we have the answer
and the user
entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over this is now this is our
local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see
everything lined up correctly
and so you've seen how in just 45
minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created we'll restart the services
say yes
i'm running on another porch because we
already have an app running on
another port so it's going to run on
3001.
refreshing the web page
and
voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good working
fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and
um make it a native application as well
right now just using it as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there we go that's your app
all up and running
hello everybody and welcome you all
so
we're gonna talk about something very
interesting topic of the day
and that is called hooks in react
see friends actually what happens
when we work on react based development
so in react 16.8 we have introduced a
new feature called react hooks
these hooks have
really changed the way how the react
development really happens
because prior to these react hooks
we were writing so much of code because
of that it actually increased the
complexity to our program
but ever since the react hooks came into
this picture the development time has
slows down
okay and we have actually increased the
productivity of our development
now how the react hook really changes
the way
this we're gonna see it now in those
slides now what are the react hooks see
the react hook is a special feature that
lets you
hook intro
now what is this
see they say fuse important thing they
say normally hook allows you to reuse a
straightforward logic without changing
your component hierarchy
your application can actually divide it
into the smaller pieces which later on
can be used together
okay so hooks let you use most of the
react features without using classes see
actually what happens
in react we have a two type of ways how
you write your components number one is
called class based component and second
which is called functional component
now
class-based components are little more
heavy lifting because it comes
pre-loaded with state management as well
as the life cycle management
but not always you need these two
so you need to keep your components
light weighted so if you want to keep
your components light weighted so you
need to basically approach towards the
state
less or functional components so by
adding those hooks features so you can
have this normal functional components
on the top of that you will be having
some add-on feature that's the beauty of
react hooks
now the rules of react hooks so there
are few rules of the react hooks which
you need to understand
and what those are number one they say
only call hooks
at the top level
don't look hooks inside loops conditions
or nested function so there are certain
conditions
they say
only hooks only call hooks from the
react function component don't call
hooks from the regular javascript
function instead you can call hook from
the react function component or call
hooks from the custom box so there are
multiple options are available which you
can expose or use in your regular
react-based applications
okay
so after that we will see the demo how
the three different type of hooks are
used straight hooks eventbooks and
create customized hook and we will see
some demo on the top of that
hello everybody so once again we are
going to start working with another type
of hook c
in our previous examples we have seen
how you can have the state related hook
now my next event will be all about how
you can have
the
even based hooks we are talking about
something called use effects so how the
usefx really works let's take a look now
so here
in a similar example if i just give the
name call
[Music]
okay let's try to make it here only so
what i'm trying to do now is in my
current application
i'm already having this count and set
count to me but
i can also provide some default values
that anyways has been provided so rather
than hard coding it i can provide it
from somewhere else so how we can so
let's use one property called props here
and here rather than providing this i'm
saying
prob start
count so my question is like what do you
mean by count here
see count is nothing but a property
which initial value i don't know so
which you can set it from outside
so what you can do is here
before you export it you can say give
the name call
hook stand dot
default props
default
props
okay equal to i'm starting with the
curly braces and after this curly braces
here saying
count
okay that value is what
zero
what initial value we're giving count
initial value equal to what a zero now
and uh post this
this value whichever we are giving it
so what we also do in the same line is
here we would like to also perform the
another actions for setting the state
initial value is called count
and
this way i can say set count count plus
1
okay that is anyways fine
so increment let me copy this
so here let me say npm space start
so i must see some values have been
presented okay you can see still
initial value was zero
that's why if you see initial value was
zero so now because of getting the
initial value called props dot count and
now i can say increment
and i want to talk about decrement so
decrement and here we say reset
so
here
we can say minus one and this value
rather than saying count plus one
okay
you can say
props dot count means whatever the
initial value would be that value will
be initialized here
so now the code will work just the way
it is now you can say increment
decrement reset
so it's working fine
so in our react hope there's an option
which is available called
life cycle hooks
life cycle books are very very important
that means you're trying to say
whenever you would like to call anything
related to your life cycle like when
your component starts you would like to
learn something when the component
you know update you want to launch
something so these kind of activities
you can certainly make it
so are you going to be making it now
let's take a look now so initially what
i'm doing is
i'm just creating a new function called
use
because it is a predefined
okay available from
okay react 16
so here onwards you can see it is coming
from the same property
from react and under this use effect
what i will do is i will just say
log and i'm saying
called
every time
now if i just launch my application and
see the inspect
you can see it is saying called every
time even if i say increment it is
getting called even decremented is
getting called and reset it will get
called
because this is a life cycle method
and the life cycle method means it will
get called
normally in a react we have a call
component dead mount and component did
update so it is a copy of both
okay
however you can
stick this particular use effect to the
specific need only like if you do not
want this to be get called on updates
only when the component launches so what
you can do here in its
comma parameter you can make it as a
square bracket
this square bracket will contain those
values which you would like to watch for
those changes so if you do not keep it
anything by default it will be what
blank so now if i just go ahead and
start it is saying called every time and
now you can say
it is not getting called at all because
now
it is knowing that hey it is a blank
value so i'm not seeing any value so it
needs to be get called only when it is
launching not every time
however you also can offer the condition
where you want to call this use effect
only when the changes happens not
every time when it is loading
so what you can do you can just call
this
again
and paste it again this use effect
insect called
on
update and here you can provide the
value which you would like to listen so
actually if i see
the state is getting changed for this
count so i can say
count and now once it is ready
i can start my application
and you can say here
increment now you can see it is getting
called
okay but it is not getting called on
loading every time
so you are specifically telling
like
this use effect should get called only
when
state changes to the account and this
you are not listening to anything so you
are making it as apply
i hope you clear about what use effect
is all about
okay everyone so the previous example we
have seen like how
this books with regards to your
current application works like as i'm
saying we're talking about like in
this
straight hook where we have seen use
effect we have also seen another feature
that is called use state and now we're
going to be talking about our next okay
everyone so now
we're continuing to our next feature
here and that is known as called use
context
see when we talk about react use context
we always have a very special feature
coming up with us where the reusability
comes as in priority
okay so if you really want to use a
reusability
okay you always think about the option
called use context now first of all i
would like to show you the problem
and then we discuss about the solution
so now here
i'm gonna say
use
context structures and in this use
context.js what are we doing i'll be
creating some few functions here i'm
saying
function
in app
okay
so in this manner i can create
const
i can say
user
set user equal to
use
state and initialize the value which
call what
admin that is the initial value we are
saying like in main app user set user
use state element
and now after this
i am using return
and in this return
with my dev tag i would like to offer
the message
okay so we are giving the name called
h2 and within this h2 we are
using this a value called
welcome and with this dollar sign
we can give the value like a user
whichever the initial value will be that
will be represented here
so that's what my first component
likewise
if i want to share the data
to the other components
how i basically try to use that's an
important thing i would like to consider
right now
so this is my first component
like i also want to create another
component which is accepting the data
and utilizing its own way
okay so like this
i can copy
and say
user2
for this function i'm creating this user
tool
in this user tool
i will not be defining any state as of
now because it is there already defined
okay so in this it will be expecting
here it will be expecting
user as in parameter
okay so return
you can defined it anything i can say
paragraph
and this i can say
[Music]
user to
component
okay and i'm saying
component 2 and now i would like to pass
this value further to another component
now
so what i'm trying to say now here
if i say user 2
let me copy this the whole bunch
and paste it below here and i'm saying
user3
which is also taking this data
and here i'm defining this value called
user3
okay space
user equal to
user
like this
we are providing it
okay
so that's where
i'm trying to use this
functionality
so we are having this function user 2
okay so after this
we are taking function 3 and adding the
data right over there
okay so this dev tag
whichever you're taking it
so we have a called main app we can say
user2 and followed by user3 so the data
we can keep on passing from one
component to another component so we
have got this component with me
user 2 and same time we have called user
3 now
ok and this user 2 whichever is
available to me
ok when you're saying hello user
this user too i can provide this data
right over here
okay so in my main application i can say
uh
user
two
okay
and with this we can provide the value
called
user equal to
once again user
like this so you can see here
we are passing the data
down the line to all my components
whichever we are utilizing it
okay
so that's fine
so
after this what we'll be doing because
we are passing the data just like that
but the only thing is what if this main
app
wants to pass the data directly to the
user three it cannot pass
okay it can pass the data to the user
three only from its immediate child
which is the user too
and that's what the problem i would like
to sort it out but here
let me say
export
default
the name is called main app
okay let's make initial capital that is
always good
okay export default main app
and let's add this main app right inside
your
app.js
okay now let's see
see the value is coming up welcome admin
welcome edmund welcome
so that's pretty fine uh components are
basically rendered but there is no
reusability if you see like it is a
plain old technique
you pass the data to the child and you
cannot pass the chat to the grandchild
these are the certain challenges
okay so let's try to sort it out this
issue
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about the solution we have already
seen our problem
there's no reusability there's no
sharing of the data
and the sharing of the data is happening
from parent to child
only when you are a direct parent
otherwise not
so how are you going to be fixing this
issue
so fix this what i'll be doing is we
just want to say
const
app context equal to
create context
okay so we're going to say equal to what
a create context
so as usual the states are there
return
now in this return what i will be doing
it i will be using this context so
anyways i'm having this dev tag
so i'll be using this option i can
use a context
or the context which you have created
that is called app content so we are
saying what
app context here okay dot
you see there's an option available
called provider this is the one which
should be helping you to share the data
to the all the components value equal to
user
okay and this app context
i would like to cut it
and paste it after here
okay and here
user to equal to user2 whatever it is
the value is there so you are passing it
to
user two
okay and later on you can pass to any
components those who want to really use
it
okay so whosoever wants to access your
context it can be easily available
okay so you really don't need to pass
this data again and again so if you are
in second component
okay so your anyways wrap the second
component right over here
so here in your second component
you really don't need this any data like
this
and you really don't need this
like that so you can easily pass this
into the user 3 also
okay so it's very simple and
straightforward
so
let me try to remove this value from
here also
and you can get the data the way you
always want
okay so
you say value equal to what
user here
so after that you are saying
user equal to what user whichever value
you are basically passing it
okay and say use context.provider
okay and the second component
when you say user2
you just say
you really don't need this in fact i
would say
you can even remove it
okay and the same you can remove it from
here also
okay and when i see my component swag
see
still working like the weight is
expected okay so that becomes the idea
of what
your
use context
okay which is designed for sharing the
data between and among the components
okay everyone so now it's time to
basically discuss about our another very
important topic that is called user f
okay use ref is basically what the use
ref you can say it is the kind of hook
which allows you to persist value
between the renders
again i'm telling you user x allows
actually to process the value between
renders
normally you can store
or you can use to store a mutable values
which are changeable
okay that does not cause
a rerender when updated
okay
that means
you can persist that value in a storage
okay as a mutable value which does not
cause
a re-render when the updates actually
happens so normally it can be used to
access your dom element directly
clear so how it can be let's take a look
with using one simple example so you all
can understand how we can utilize this
okay so i'm going to create another one
here
name call
use ref.js
inside this user.js so let's get started
with this implementations the one which
we're looking at right now so called
userf so once again i'm creating
a function
app
and inside this i would like to say
const
input
vl
comma
set
input val
equal to
user state
okay
we want to use it now we want to use one
more const
value
okay equal to now we would like to say
use ref you can see it is coming once
again from the where from the react here
in this user we can pass initial value
black we do not have initial values so
that we are sending it as a what is a
blank
now post that
we want to create
first important thing is we would like
to use the use effect first use
effect you have already seen the use
effect earlier because it is holding the
life cycle related
conditions so now here we are saying
prep value
okay dot
current
equal to
input val
okay and after that which value you are
seeing
to be get updated so we are passing
input valve for sure
okay
post that once it is ready okay i will
be saying return
okay inside this return
i'm having
dev tag
and here in this step type we can say
input type
equal to
text
okay value
equal to which value would like to take
it so we are giving
input val
okay and we are also saying on change
equal to
taking this e is an event object here
and
we're calling
set
input val
with
e dot
target dot
value
okay
so we are holding the values
just like this
okay and after this once it is ready i
just want to use the
s3 tag
to show what is the current value we can
say
updated value
okay here
i'm having this input value with me
and now i'll be using one more
h2 we are saying
last value
of
using
priv
value
okay dot
current
so that's where you are basically using
so
this will be offering you what
the kind of value you are actually
expecting into your program
okay so use ref hooks can be used to
keep track of the previous state values
this is what we're doing it now
okay so this is because we are able to
persist use reference value between the
render so now let me try to say
export
default
and
i'm just giving the name of
app and this app i'm using it here in my
app.js
app me terminate it and
launch it again
[Music]
let's see
blue color 3000 again
so it is taking some more time but i'm
sure
we'll be able to see the outcome
soon into our system so now you can see
these values are coming up so now when i
pass the value call
one it is containing the one when i say
two you can see it is holding the
previous value when i say three it
containing the previous value when i say
for it holding the previous value
that's where exactly the beauty of this
user of which you are expecting it from
all of you
so everyone we have already seen like
our previous example like how we can use
the use ref in our previous project now
it's time to talk about
our another interesting feature in hooks
continuation to this
and that we're talking about for working
with a use reducer
so what is the use reducer see use
reducer
is again a hook
which is as same as like an user state
okay it allows for
custom state logic
unlike the normal state how we maintain
using new state allows to help
having some custom logic also see if you
are finding yourself where we have
called multiple portions of the state
that actually depends on the complex
logic
use reducer would be very very
beneficial for you because it contains a
centralized logic
okay and can help the users to develop
some more fantastic applications so
let's see how we can actually do this
and how we can utilize that so in hooks
demo
i'm going to create a new file here i'm
going to give the name called
not app.js
and in this node.js i would like to have
some initialize state i won't like to
make it available to the user
so
let's try to use one
very simple logic call
const
note reducer
not
reduces equal to here
i would like to take the parameter like
in state
and
action it is just like a normal
functionality we are writing it down
and inside this we would like to use a
switch
here we use a switch and we will judge
what type of action client is trying to
invoke action this is what kind of
condition clients to client is ready to
invoke i'm using action
dot
type
okay
and here we use the first option like in
case
first
condition i'm taking it is called
populate nodes
okay
populate underscore
nodes which all the existing nodes are
available populated
okay and here
after this
we would like to say return
[Applause]
dot
nodes
okay or else in a default case
or in a default case we are saying
return
the default state whichever is available
to me
so that's how the condition is now
going back
i would like to also check what are the
type of
states are available which i would like
to show it back to the client so we are
using this option like it
cost
let's create a states first we are
saying const
nodes
comma
dispatch
equal to use
reducer and inside this rule is the
first parameter we are passing is called
node reducer whichever we have taken as
an action here
and comma the initial state which i am
making it is a blank
i do not have any states of making it as
a blank again i am using this option
again const
title
set title equal to
use
state with initial value blank
so that's how we are passing it now
okay now the next thing is like i would
like to
check
in my code
how to basically display the list of
nodes back to my application
okay that's what the whole logic i want
to write
okay so let's check in case if i want to
return
the bulk of nodes how do i do this
so here
let's try to create the
notes app so
this i would to make it
that was the reducer for us
now here we're going to create const
node
and i'm closing it here
okay so we are having these two
properties with me
and
we can have a number of actions also
but let's talk about return
in this return
we want to display the list of nodes
which are available to me
in case if i'm having it i will display
it so
i'm having the dip tag
inside this tab tag i can say
h2
notes
after this notes
notes
dot
map in case if i'm having a array of
notes map is a predefined function
for me so here we are using what
note
okay so
so inside this we would like to provide
the
object where the details will be
available to me
okay so
i can use
the div tag
where i can have the property with me so
i can use
the div
okay so i can use
key
equal to
we can just use
the default state which is available
called nodes
equal to what notes
and provide
the other details too like if you want
to iterate it so you can just provide
the data accordingly
okay so
that's what the whole idea is and here
under this we would like to provide
note
okay
and
here if in case if i want to have some
data that can be displayed
okay so
now say
export
default
not app
and this note up i'll be making it as a
child of app.js
okay
so you can see i have got initial data
displaying here so in case if i have few
more records
suppose if i set data
okay so you can basically make
this data also available here so you can
see i've got list of records are
available
okay so
that's make your development even more
easier
and that's the beauty of how the nodes
can be used for the further development
okay so i hope you're clear about
what in case if i want to use
uh you know this reducer
so how we can further utilize it to
initialize
the data with this
but later on if i want to add some
actions
i can also add it
okay but this is what the initial state
which we are using it
in case if i want to display the data in
my code
hello everyone so in the previous
sections we have seen like
how we will be utilizing
our
you know use reducer applications now
i'm going to tell you about another
react very popular tool that is known as
called use memo which is once again a
very very popular
tool so what is the user memo it is
again another hook
so
use memo hook return some memorized
value what it was the previous value was
so we can
say think of
uh
memorization as a caching value so that
it does not need to be recalculated it
already contain the value within that
so use memo only runs when
of its dependency update
okay so use memo
okay
is one of the very very popular tool but
it can be
you know little expensive resource
insensitive function
okay so it is
used memo can be used to keep expensive
and resource oriented function
to avoid needlessly running so we will
see how this
use memo can work
so let's check this out and see
see
what my intention is in my application
is like
use memo is basically perform
some
actually memorized your complex
calculations so that it doesn't need to
run unnecessary every time
okay so it does a kind of caching
behavior for you to make your life even
more simple so let's see how it works so
accordingly you will also get the
implementations
okay so
you need to understand the use memo hook
accept the second parameter
okay to declare dependencies so the
expensive function would only run when
this dependency has been changed
otherwise not
okay so let's see how we will be using
those so now here
i'm creating a new file and give the
name call
[Music]
okay so inside your memo app.js what you
do is just take a look let me try to
close rest of those
yeah so here we see
okay so we are saying
set count
equal to
user state initialize value with what
i would say zero
for a time being i'm trying to use now
okay
and uh
after that if i want to perform some
calculations i can do that but let me
try to perform this job only okay count
and set count according to my
rule
okay now
what i'm planning to do now is in a
similar line
i want to offer one more feature here
called const
cost to do
equal to use state
i'm making it as a what type area type
okay and i'm saying
const
calculation equal to
expensive calculation
and here we are passing what
counters and parameter here
okay now let's perform some functions
i'm saying const
increment equal
to set count
c
plus one
okay and we are using
we're calling this set to dos here
okay and use
all the previous states whichever are
available and
new data this will get added so three
functions you are basically calling
after that i am saying
return
in this return i am having what
div tag
within this div tag i can use
another tip tag here and here we're
using
my
after this h2 we would like to use
todos dot
map
slash what index
and here we saying return
paragraph
sorry key
equal to
add task
okay and
here
sorry
equal to what
index here
and here
totals
[Music]
okay
how do you make it
okay so this is how we have it now
after this we would like to create a one
button
inside this button i can say
add to do
and here
we will say one click and in on click
will be calling
at task
so this is what it is happening now
okay everybody
so
here after this div tag is getting
closed
hr is getting closed
again we are opening up another div tag
here
and here we are seeing
count
and here we're using
in this button we would like to
click on plus
increment what we're calling it here
increment here and
call something called
calculation
just like a normal message
and here
put what
calculation
okay so once it is done
so your dip tag is also close
both the two tags are kind of getting
close
okay and they are also getting close and
now
we would like to perform one function
whichever i would like to use it for my
standard calculation
okay so let's see what we are trying to
do
so here i am saying
power running calculation equal to
okay and we are using this
lock button insert this lock button i'm
saying
calculating here and uh post this
business call for
let
i equal to zero
i is
less than
[Music]
okay and we're using what
i
plus plus
and say
num
equal to one
okay
and after this
i can say
return
now
and after that i'll be rendering this
function
by saying
export default memoir
that's it
okay so this would be my application
here
okay so now
here in this example
the expensive function which is called
long running function
okay
whatever i'm talking about
the long running function
okay will only run when the count is
changed
and not when the to-do's are added
that's a whole picture about this code
here
okay so you can just see here
we're using this statement
and uh
here
we're gonna give the name of this
long running calculations
to here
okay so i'm calling it there
now this memo app i'll be using it in my
app.js
okay so that is what we have it now so
i'm clearly saying like here
so
in this application
hook accept second parameter to declare
dependency this exp so the long running
functions will only run when the
dependency have changed otherwise not
that's the whole picture
so it is adding it saying calculating it
and then it is getting changed
okay
so that's what the whole picture of what
we have done so i'm sure like you all
are clear
about how
this memo
is really performing some job the one
which is actually expected
and once again we're going to start with
another feature of books as we have got
many hooks seen in our development
okay and
now on this top of this i'll be working
on our new concept that is what's called
use imperative handler it is again a new
concept as we have already seen multiple
different type of
hooks into our development now we'll be
talking about use imperative handler
now what is the use of
this particular hook look when we talk
about use imperative handler if i just
get you this
so if i say
use
now when we talk about use imperative
handler
okay so this use imperative handler and
the user is what we've already done
allows to pass a reference object
but the later which is called
use reference
which you've already seen
this use reference
doesn't allow to customize the instance
that are
also passed with the ref object so use
imperative handler hooks is a different
from user friends
because it allows again it allows
handling and customizing the return
value
it allows handling
and customizing the return value
and it also allows to replace the native
instance of the ref object
now how it works let's try to understand
in our development
so
here we're going to start working with a
very simple approach
into our code
okay
so we're going to create a new one that
is called
[Music]
imperativedemo.js and after this we are
writing
function
converter
okay here we are passing two parameters
here one is called
props and seconds call what
two parameters we are passing it
now here we are saying
const
use riff
okay
now
after this we're using use
you can see we have called use
imperative handler comes from
this one so we are using this use
impellative handler and here we are
passing what refers in parameter
okay and
okay now in this case we are using one
type of functionality called blur
okay and here
with this blur
and we are using
log
and writing
custom blur is called
after this once it is ready i would like
to say return
in this return we are saying button
okay
and with this button
i want to use rift
okay equal to
btn and
props
we both are passing in here
in this using
click
okay
that's it and once it is done then
we would like to
use this
okay into my application
wherever i can actually access this
in my application to system
so once it is ready i would like to make
it
available so by using i'm saying export
default and i'm using something called
forward reference
you can see it is again a part of what
the react application we are using is
called forward reference
and here we are passing what
button so that is what my code is
now here
i will be making it as a child off but
uh
in my app.js so we already have this
earlier
memo app so here in my application
i'm just using const
btn equal to
use reference
i'll be using what use reference
so react
okay so we're using this option called
use reference here and we are passing
null here and after this
this value whichever we are having it we
just said cut
and passing it here and this under this
written keyword i'm using
button
and in this button in our
options i can provide the events
so inside this button we would like to
one second
yep
so inside this button using
on click
equal to
we're saying btn
okay dot
current dot
okay so we haven't imported
anything so let me import a button from
here
okay so we say
import
button
which class we have created here
imperative demo
okay
so
so once it is there so
[Music]
um
so we're providing what
btn.current.com blur
so closing this here and along with this
we are saying ref
equal to
btn
that's it
so this is where exactly the
options are so you understand in this
particular example we have developed a
custom button component that has a user
defined instance attached to the
reference object
attached to the what the reference
object now so we have developed a button
component that has a user defined
instance attached to the reference
object so button component is the child
component of the app component
are we clear so when we click the button
here
the button is clicked
okay it called user defined blur
function which is attached to the pass
reference object
okay so that's the whole idea now
so i haven't tried anything another
button
that certainly i can add it
so under here
okay
so now
okay so
here
the things are working the way we were
expecting
okay so you see like what we did here is
now
we are now
using this approach
okay you see like we are using this
approach with using this
use empirical reference so we have a
call function button
we're passing two parameter props in ref
so we're getting this use reference
object
and use imperative we are passing this
ref
and this object here so we are using
this blur
as in the kind of custom objects where
console.log custom
properties getting called a reference
button equal to
button and you're saying dot dot props
click here button and export default
forward reference button here
and followed by app.js
we are just using this
normal app component
const but in equal to use reference null
return we're returning this button
one click
you see here equal to btn
okay it's just a reference what you're
using dot current dot blur
and uh after that it's getting close
using f equal to what btn whichever
you're referring it and that's it so the
job is done
[Music]
so friends now after this the previous
example we have seen called imperative
now it's time to basically discuss about
another very interesting example that is
called use layout effect there is
another hook which is available to you
so this use layout effect actually works
similar
okay
to use use effect but rather working
asynchronously like what a use effect
does because use effect works
asynchronously
it fires synchronously after all loading
is done
again i'm repeating
the use layout effect works similar to
use effect but rather than
but rather working asynchronously like
how the use effect works okay what it
does is it basically it fires
synchronously after all dom
is done loading so this is pretty useful
for normally a synchronously
re-rendering the dom
okay so it is very useful for
synchronously re-rendering the dom and
also to read the layout
from the dock
but to prevent
blocking the page loading we should
always use use effect otherwise it will
block so the use
layout effect okay works in the same
phase as component did mount and
component did update methods we should
only use use effect
layout effect if use effect is not
outputting the expected result
so let's take a look with a simple
example of the one which we are looking
forward for
okay so here in my code what we're doing
is
we're going to give the new file name
called use
but yes
okay so let me add
const
layout
okay
and here we're using cost
equal to
use state
and give any value whichever you would
like to give it okay let's say
welcome
and after that
you come down and say
use layout effect
okay and say if
value
equal to
welcome
i am saying
set value
welcome to react hooks
okay so that's an expectations and after
that we are using what
the log and inside this lens is saying
used layout is working
okay with value so
using what the value here
okay
and
whenever the value changes
and listening to what the value here
and after this when we talk about return
so you have to return the value history
okay so we say
return
inside this div we will say
value
that's it
and after this
in here
okay
so once it is ready you will see here
in your program
here we need to check
[Music]
so
value okay
fine so here i need to use
to make it okay so now
i go to the inspect
go to the console
let's refresh
and now you can see it is loading
synchronously
okay
so your application is now loading the
way it is expected
used out is working well it is working
you can do the react it's perfect so
that's where the idea of this particular
example so
in this example we have built a name
changer application that changes the
name of the state when the use layout
effect is called
okay and it's working fine
okay everyone so now if it is ready then
we'll be talking about our next feature
here
that is called working with
use debug value
this is once again another hook
of the react based development
so when we talk about use double value
so what use debug value actually does
and
what we uh really do with the use debug
value this we would like to understand
okay see what happens not too many
developers nowadays know about
use debug value hook okay though
although it provides a much better
debugging experience when it comes to
the developing custom books so use debug
value is a simple inbuilt hook that
provides more information about the
logical
of a custom mode within a reactive tool
so react devtool is a tool which you can
get it uh downloaded for your chrome
extension
okay
and
it allows you to display the additional
information
okay
next to your hooks with optional
formatting
okay so that's what the
redux
react
views debug value is basically be useful
for
now how you basically use this so you
can just consider in this way
if i just go back and create a new file
and give the name called used value
use
debug.js
okay
so inside this youtube.js
here we would like to use function
and in function we can use this option i
can use
friend status
use frame status so here
we can say
trend
and here we can use const
is
online
set
online equal to
user state
we are providing the value
okay and now here we use this option i
can use
debug value and here i told you is
online
question mark
here we say
online
okay and here
we say what
okay and after this we are talking about
this option
okay
so that's where exactly you perform
this condition for after that what you
can do you can just use this option i
can export
default
trendline online status
so this is where you can
basically perform this online debugging
sorry the debugging for all the
react hooks whichever you're looking for
so this is very popular and utilized and
useful option for the regular users
hello everybody and welcome you all so
today we have a very interesting session
coming up for this react which is called
react router so let's get started with
react router and see what it offers
so friends the first important thing
about what is the routing as we know it
very well the routing is synonyms of
navigation
any application whether you talk about
multi-page application or single page
application it always requires a routing
through this routing you will be making
your applications
uh you know to be navigate from one part
to the another part like you have called
login page registration page and you
have got a lot of links available
and when you click on those links
application will take you towards those
necessary pages but here in react these
are component centric architecture
so here you will be having a components
loaded
okay
so as we know in a traditional web
development routing plays a very very
crucial role so that you can navigate
through
okay
now
react router so what is the react router
so we know this react router is a client
and server side routing library provided
by the rehack it is a javascript
libraries which is normally known for
creating the attractive user interfaces
now here the traditional react router is
available on the web
okay and the server
so
with using traditional node.js
based application which is you know it
is designed for developing a server-side
java based javascript based applications
and on react networks once again for
mobile phase environment for react
applications
now react router components so browser
router so typical we say the browser
router is this is one of the component
because react router comes with lot many
apis so here's one of the api which is
called browser router so browser router
is something from where okay it uses the
traditional html5 history api which is
one of the main component
so it keeps your
url in sync with what you are navigating
through
okay so next we have a call routes
so routes are basically chosen based on
what best matches you are providing it
so that when you click on those links so
appropriate root will get loaded for you
so called components
so now we have a call link so the
traditional link components are used to
basically create a hyperlinks like ahref
how we used in html pages so
to different
from the traditional react apple
application so it is mainly designed
focus on navigation throughout the
applications
and now we have a call switch so
traditionally switch what it does it
renders the first routes and matches the
location rather than rendering all the
matching route like whichever has come
it is like a typical switch case
whichever comes it make it available and
come out
that's how it provides
okay so installation wise you need to
have
first
you have to create the react based
application by using
npx create react app so
create react app is a tool provided by
the
official facebook and the router hyphen
tutorial is the name of the project
okay so you'll be using this command to
create a new project for you and post
that
you have to install
this particular dependency called react
hyphen now to hyphen dom so this
dependence you need to install
post
first
i would say
the message is executed so once the
first command is ready then you will be
going inside this npm
install and then you say react router
down so this is how the steps are
and
now we'll talk about demo so let's get
started with the demo part
okay everybody so it's time to
get into some hands-on
so i already have a project ready with
me which we have created with using
create react app so my project name is
react hyphen app
and i would like to create a new
uh
router based example here so the
dependency regarding react hyphen router
hyphen dom is already
installed so if you see this
package.json react router dom is already
there in place
so we would like to start now
developing those router based examples
so to make it happen what we will do is
here in my src
we will create a new folder named
components
okay and inside this components
we will create some file name called
login.js
[Music]
likewise we would like to create a
register
user
details.js
more
name call
portfolio
so we have got these pages already with
me
okay
out of which i want the first components
to be get launched here that is called a
landing page so here i will also create
landing page.js
so let's go back and create any
components here which will be helping us
to
move
here and there
so first thing in my landing page my
component.js i have a call app.js which
is a
base component for me
so as i can see this is how you go back
and create a new functional component so
i just copy the same
and here in login.js we paste it
and give the name to
login
login and here we can say welcome to
login i just
this is my small component i copied
and i pasted it in the portfolio
so you can portfolio welcome to
portfolio
register
register
login you know call user details
okay so we have got these components
with us
i will start with
landing page first
so
i would like to create a class based
component here
so
import
to react
from
react
now
4d for class
landing page
exchange
component
now
render
return
okay so this is
the one we call tube tag here
well
this is my component which is available
to me
so the landing page is a component which
through which i'll start working on
so
[Music]
i can say
welcome to landing so here i want this
components to be available outside
so what i will do is this landing page
in my index.js
i'll make it as a first component to be
launched
landing page
so when i start my application i should
see here
okay welcome to lending is coming up
perfect
so this has become my first component
which i
want to launch and furthermore we would
like to add few more components here
okay so in a previous program we have
seen
how to create a multiple components and
how we can make one of the component as
a
learning component now it's our next
program where we will be enabling the
routing into our code
syllable landing page we would like to
create some more dependency we are
saying import
from
react hyphen router hyphen dom
so we will be choosing those
dependencies one by one but from there
we want to start working with
cons routes
equal to
first thing
as we discuss with you that is we would
like to start with the browser router
okay
so
from this point onwards you would like
to start with
switch
as you can see they are taking from the
react router down
after the switch we will say
route
okay so here
with this route we would like to see the
navigation path we say path
equal to if it is login
then which component i want to launch so
we can say
component
here it says c small
component equal to
okay
it's not loading so we can say import
and since i want to launch
the component which is a type of login
so we can say import
from login
so if you see here
we work for login so we will be using
this login only
okay
so this is my login component likewise i
will say
from
register so here
we would like to say
login
and in a similar way
we also want to have the another
registration
we copy the same
use this
register
register
so this is how the components are used
here
okay
well
these are the quick two components we
have created one is called logger and
seconds for register
after that what you will be doing this
routes you will be adding it under this
div tag so i'm removing this landing
page
and here
i will give the name call
routes
that's it
so once this route has been given
now it's time for us to
see
what it differs so landing page
or sorry we have a register we have a
register also
so
[Music]
say route is not defined so what we can
do
we can also import it out from this page
now let's go back
okay nothing is shown so now we have to
manually type by saying
login you can see i've got this message
for welcome to login
now let's see register
and there we go register
so two components are loaded correctly
now we would like to import two more
import
portfolio
portfolio
okay
and last
we have a call user details
import
name call
user details here
so we got user details let me copy these
two
so register
portfolio
so this is how
our components are so now
we can see all the registered
successfully
well in our previous program we have
seen we were typing those urls manually
into our browser
but in real time this won't be a
solution
in a real time you would like to make
this example
by clicking on a hyperlink you would
like to make it possible
so i will be doing this
so to make it possible what you will be
doing is like here itself you create a
new
component called
header
okay
so this is how you're going to create
the new component called header
okay so within this
you're going to add
the new
act called header within this you will
be using
nav link which is once again
the tool provided by
react to which you can create a
hyperlinks
so this is the nav link for you
so within the snap link you will provide
the option like in two
equal to
login
and
along with this you will also provide
the name so here i say
login let me copy the same
login
register
register
we also have called
last we have called
portfolio
so this is my component which is
available to me and this i would like to
use
within my application so here
after this browser router
we would like to add the component call
header here
that's it that's the only thing we need
to do now this header component is now
the part of
routes and let's see how it makes a
difference now you can see
very clearly it is having those links
with me and now when i click on those
links
you can see how these are easily
accessible to all of us
okay so these are the links which are
available to us through which we can
make our components
simple and easy to access
one more thing we can do it here
and what's that this component whichever
we are talking about okay
this component we can attach
to one of my
base component when my components start
it should work automatically so i can do
one thing like my login component to be
the base component for me
so in order to make this possible i need
to write one more tool here called
exact equal to
true
and here also we have to use the same
so here
we would like to add one more property
here
okay and we will say exact equal to true
okay what i would like to use
exact equal to true
that's it any job is done now let's
check
and now you can see the by default login
page appeared
because the login is in root location
and that's all
your url works
okay everybody so in a previous examples
we have seen how the links are working
but these links are all internal links
but what in case if i want to go to the
external link so let's try to understand
that point so here let me try to open up
i'm opening up simply learn link
and i'm clicking on this
the url is right now https
simplydone.com
that's a link which is available so let
me try to copy this link
and
[Music]
here
if you want to go to that location so
what do we need to do now
so to make it possible
here i can just make this another nav
link
copy the same
and i give the name called
simpler and
and here i'll just copy the same
okay
so now it is asking me for the component
because i do not have any component here
right now
so here what i will be doing instead
i am making it as a blank
okay and here
i want to give window
dot location
dot
href
equal to
the website which is available
okay so that will be the link which i'm
providing it now
and
after this link what has been provided
i'm saying
return
that's it
okay so that'll be the link
so i'm saving this and going back to
this
location now
so you can see we have a call simply
that the moment i click it here
so
it will somehow try to take me towards
where
this external website the one which
we're actually looking forward for
okay so this is the
way which you can basically make
the application accessible outside so if
i just go back to my browser and
[Music]
refresh this and click on signal and you
can see now it took me to an external
location called simplyland.com
likewise if i just go back and open
the
simple learn
as a youtube channel
also just say
okay simply do
youtube so if any of the
i would say
the
link which is available right you can
see right now we have got
multiple websites so if i just click on
anything suppose
this is a link for me
and
i try to create one more link here
just like we have a call simply learn so
let's create one more and i say
simply learn youtube
simply on youtube so here
i copy the same
okay so here
in my browser whatever the link is
provided let's just copy this link
and paste this link right over there
okay so this is what a link which is
available to me
now i go back to my code
like i said simply learn youtube i click
it
and you can see it took me two way to
the right
so this is the way you see
how the links are basically created
and they're simply available to us
in a very simplified manner
okay and that's where
the hyperlinks are basically working
with us
welcome to the session on react.js
interview questions through this session
we will explore the most commonly posed
interview questions that you would face
if you walk up to a developer interview
on react.js let's start with going
through and exploring the general set of
react.js interview questions that would
be commonly asked in an interview the
first question would be what are the
features of react.js now right through
this session we would follow a common
methodology where we would explore the
question and then look at the best way
in which you could have answered that
question if posed to you during a
react.js interview so starting with the
first question what are the features of
react so react has many extensions for
complete application architecture
support jsx is used with react to
describe what the user interface should
typically look like react is broken into
small components so you look at the
complete application you want to build
break it down into individual components
and a component is typically a piece of
user interface like a function that
would return a stream of html characters
speedy performance is one of the core
features of react as only the updated
components need to be re-rendered on the
screen and not the entire page the
one-way data binding feature on the
other hand keeps everything modular and
fast the virtual dom is also a
lightweight representation of the real
dom which is again a feature with helps
speed up performance and avoids a full
page refresh and a full dom tree shake
which really speeds up performance so
what is jsx how do you answer this so
jsx is typically the extension used for
react and it's nothing but an extension
to the javascript programming language
because all that you can use inside your
browser for execution typically has to
be javascript because in html5 you
cannot have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only ship by
default with a javascript runtime engine
so by using jsx you can write html
structures in the same file that would
contain your javascript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code in the business logic
is in a single file it makes
updating and incorporating change
requests uh to the code very simple and
easy so it's basically used with react
to describe what your user interface
should look like and it's what you
typically would term as the html
template or the view coming to the next
question can gsx be directly read by the
web browser so web browsers cannot read
jsx directly now why is that well the
reason is simple it's because they are
only built to read regular javascript
objects and jsx is not a regular
javascript objects it's a react
component so for a web browser to read a
jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular javascript
object and for this there is a
javascript api called babel which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
gives a very lightweight representation
of the real dom the actual dom structure
of the page so dom is document object
model it is
an api created by w3c and it creates an
in-memory representation of the html
elements as an inverted tree structure a
balanced tree structure which is the
fastest search algorithm when you want
to search for html elements and do a
dynamic update on them but again
updating the basic dom tree structure of
the page causes a full page refresh and
if you only want to update a specific
component you wouldn't need the entire
page to be refreshed and that is where
react comes in it uses a virtual dom
which is a layer on top of the actual
dom which ensures that only a certain
part of the page is refreshed and that
speeds up performance so when the state
of an object changes virtual tom changes
only that object in the real dom instead
of updating all the objects and this is
what makes things really fast so why use
react instead of other frameworks like
angular first of all it's very easy to
create dynamic web pages dhtml where you
can update the view or the template at
runtime the components are reusable so
you reuse rather than reinvent the
performance is great since you're
working with the virtual dom you don't
need a full page refresh the
unidirectional data flow makes data move
one way there's no two-way data binding
by default and that's the reason the
page does not have to do a lot of heavy
lifting of remembering whether the view
is changing whether the the base
javascript entity class is changing and
that saves a lot of uh processing time
again to debug react is much more
simpler and that's what makes it more
popular in terms of its simplicity and
speed as compared to other frameworks
like angular what is the difference
between es5 and es6 standard so these
are scripting standards okay that are
defined by the european computer
manufacturers association or ecma and
all of the scripting languages
are a subset of the standard and are
derived from these standards to ensure
that the code will execute on all
browsers and the code that we are
writing is standards based so these are
the few instances where es6 syntax has
changed from es5 if you look at the es5
first syntax at the top we are creating
a simple react class component and the
render function just returns a stream of
html content in ex6 there's a new
keyword that comes in which is extends
so you are extending from the base react
component and creating a custom
component and then returning a stream of
characters also the function keyword no
longer needs to be used so the exports
versus export also changes so you use
exports to export out class from a
module so that it can be accessed from
another module in es6 you simply say
export and the component require versus
import so you would require a third
party component or an api into your
javascript file to use it in es6 it's
replaced with the import statement very
similar to the syntax that we use in
code java so how do you go and create a
react app first you install node.js as a
base platform which you can download
from the node.js website next any text
editor of your choice could be atom
visual studio code or sublime text third
you create a react app using a command
prompt terminal depending on the os you
are using the command to give is create
hyphen react space my first app okay so
the command that you would give to
create a new react app is create hyphen
react hyphen app space and the name of
the application you would want to create
in this case it is my hyphen first
hyphen app and that could be a custom
name of your choice so what is an event
in react well on the web when you talk
about dynamic html it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action
can be triggered by a user or any system
or could be pressing a key or a mouse
click etc and in response to that event
you would execute a block of code which
is called an event handler so here we
have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
html when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one api which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function action link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.lock which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to the html template where on click
we connect to this event handler called
handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
action link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand an
enclave some another browser would
understand a click and to ensure that
it's consistency of syntax and from a
development perspective the code that we
write will run on all browsers we need
to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the lists display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props dot names
will allow us to get a reference to all
of the array of names that are passed
constant list names is another variable
created equal to start map and
we are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and
again we are using the opening tag of
the li html element the key is equal to
the name attribute so the brace bracket
will bind that to the name attribute
then we just print the name itself and
we close the li tag so that's the
names.map function and finally we return
in an unordered list the list names
themselves so the map function will run
through and iterate over the list of
names list them in the li tag the li tag
will get injected into the unordered
list and will finally get returned out
as a stream of html elements in the next
code snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that
we are using list of names as a custom
html element which is not system defined
it starts looking for the function list
of names passes the names area to it
iterates over it using the map function
which is an inbuilt react function
brings out all of the lists it's very
similar to a forward loop that you would
write for iteration in other programming
languages and then finally what you get
returned in the get element by id app is
nothing but a list of simple names
wrapped in a li element that are printed
on the view so why is there a need of
using keys in lists so keys are very
important in the code snippet that we
saw due to the following reasons the
first reason the key is a unique
identifier if you would want to search
for a name in the list it is used to
identify which items have changed
updated or deleted from the list so if
you want to perform cred operations on
the data you would want to search for
which element do you want to update or
delete or change it also helps to
determine which components need to be
rerendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication
searching filtering etc how do you
create a form pretty simple again create
a custom component called name from that
will extend reactor component we create
a state variable this dot state is equal
to value we handle the change by writing
a handle change event and we handle the
submit by writing a handle submit event
in the change event we just change the
state by saying set state of the value
to event or target dot value event being
a system defined keyword passed as a
parameter and in the submit we simply
alert that a certain name was entered
and we trapped the value that was
entered into the form prevent default to
suppress the browser from raising any
errors on the render function we return
a form on the submit we connect to the
handle submit event and we bind the data
submitted from the form to the handle
submit event and we pass the this
pointer which is a reference to the
current context of the view itself we
open a label specify the name we then
specified input box as text the value is
set to this dot state dot value and on
change we simply connect to the handle
change event and bind to it and pass the
context of the text box itself so the
moment we change the value in the text
box as we are typing the handle change
event will receive the updated value and
set the state and when we click on the
submit button the handle submit event
handler executes and we alert out the
current value printed in the text box
and that's it so how do you write
comments in react when you're a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set comments
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash asterisk to open
astrix to close multi-line commands
follow the same syntax and can span
multiple slides to add comments to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e arrow operator this dot
handle on change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operator and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013 it's a web-based platform it is
html compliant it generates html views
it uses css for styling and it's based
on javascript html and css react native
on the other hand is targeted to
mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on android and ios
released in 2015 not based on html and
css and it basically requires the
react.js api to create these installable
apps for these mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular another
popular framework by google so angular
created by google completely based on
the model view controller pattern works
on the real dom layer and requires a
full tree shake at the tom layer to
update views and components supports
bi-directional data mining the rendering
is purely done on the client side the
performance comparatively slow react.js
on the other hand created by facebook
it's the view layer of the model view
controller pattern it works at the
virtual dom layer and it sends faster
it's unidirectional data binding and not
two-way and the rendering is typically
what is done at the server side and what
you get as a response on the client as a
stream of html characters as an output
let's talk about and discuss some
questions around react components so
what are components in react so these
are the building blocks you can think of
them as lego blocks so you break your
problem down into small parts each part
identifying a certain solution of the
problem which is what we define as a
component so they are building blocks of
a react application and a single app
usually consists of multiple components
so it splits the ui into independent
reusable pieces that can be processed
separately a component is essentially a
piece of the user interface or the html
view what is the use of render method in
react so it is compulsory for each
component to have a render method if not
there wouldn't be any html for the
component to render on your view so the
render function returns the html which
is to be displayed within a component
like you see on the screen that is a
class app that extends the react
component and it returns a simple h1
element called hello simply learn and of
course do remember to export the app out
so that it can be accessed from other
components as well if you need to render
more than one element all the elements
must be inside a single parent tag like
a div or a form what is state in react
the state of a component is an object
that holds some data within it the data
would influence the output of the
component now how do you implement state
in react so state holds the data that a
component renders on the web application
for example here we've created in the
constructor this dot state equal to and
this temporary anonymous object has two
attributes car and pi when we return we
simply return this dot state dot car and
this dot state dot by now this is how
you would create stateful components and
access the state properties within the
view how do you update the state of a
component by using the built-in set
state method you can go ahead and update
the state of the component so here we
have a simple render function that
returns the state itself state dot
message and on the on click connects to
a button press function the moment you
click on the button the button press
function sets the state to another
message so the initial message in the
constructor is welcome to simply learn
the moment you click on the button the
set state triggers and changes it to
best place to learn so the data on the
view would be updated what are props in
react well props is just a short form
for properties and that is what allows
us to pass arguments or data to a
component props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of attributes
that are passed to an html element so
how do you pass props between two
components so let's say we have an
app.js component on the top and a
main.js component at the bottom at the
top we are trying to return this dot
props dot car and the bike so two car
and bike attributes associated with this
props of the app component in the main
component when you look at the render
function we are associating car prop
equal to a value of 1 600 cc and bike
prop equal to value of 1 5 0 cc and to
access it if you look at the import
statement we are importing app from
app.jsx and this is how you can cross
access properties from one component
within the other so what are the
difference between state and props well
state holds information about the
components they are mutable they can be
changed they cannot be accessed by child
components and they cannot have state
props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react dom uh we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply learn
would be the final output and that's how
you can embed one component into the
other using this methodology what are
the differences between class and
functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders
this.props.title
the constant stateless component would
be equal to props the div tag returns
this dot props dot title so you can look
at the style very different in terms of
class and functional components one
using the arrow operator one using the
traditional class and render method so
the class component can hold or manage
state complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed state they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any life cycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
life cycle methods of components we've
got guinness initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the dom
and returns true or false value based on
certain conditions component did update
it is invoked immediately after the
rendering takes place component will
unmount which is invoked immediately
before a component is destroyed and
unmounted permanently let's move to the
react redux set of questions so what is
redux it's an open source javascript
library used to manage application state
and react uses redux for building the
user interface what are components of
redux the first is the store which holds
the state of the application store
contains state which defines the user
interface which triggers a set of
actions which are then sent to the
reducer so store holds the state action
is the source information for the store
and reducer specifies how the
application state changes in response to
actions sent to the store what is flux
well flux is the application
architecture that facebook uses for
building web applications and it works
in this way the action is triggered
which is sent to the dispatcher the
dispatcher sends it to the store the
store sends it to the view and the view
sends it back to the action and that's
exactly how the steps would continue in
sequence so when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified once
the dispatcher has dealt with an action
the stores listening to it will get
triggered the view gets updated when the
state of the store changes user action
at the view is sent to the dispatcher to
then be processed how is redux different
from flux redux is an open source
javascript library used to manage
application state the store state is
immutable it can only have a single
store and it uses the concept of reducer
flux on the other hand is an
architecture and not a framework or
library the store state is mutable it
can have multiple stores and it uses the
concept of dispatcher let's look at some
react router questions what is a react
router a react router is a package which
is used to create routing in a react
application react router is used for
developing single page web applications
it allows multiple views in a single
application by defining multiple routes
in that react application how is react
routing different from conventional
routing react routing has a single html
page it uses or the end user rather
would navigate multiple views within the
same file called a single page app the
page does not refresh since it's a
single page file and there is improved
performance since you are not navigating
across multiple pages conventional
routing each view is a separate html
file the user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route part is just
slash the route defaults out it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the url given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the url is slash contact it would
take you to the contact component let's
talk about react styling questions how
do you style react components either you
use inline styling by using simple css
by simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the h1 element
or i could use a javascript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypair value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a css style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate css file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of css
modules in react so a css module file is
created.module.css is the extension the
css inside a module file is available
only for the component that is importing
it so there are no naming conflicts so
dot button is the css styling inside
button.module.css
and that is what we've imported from in
the app.js file so when you view the
button style start button is the styling
picked up from the button.module.css
file so let's talk about some
introduction to react context
now first important thing we need to
understand
a typical application when we talk about
react application so data is always
passed through what from the top down
approach with the help of props as we
know it very well
if we have a component like an a b and c
and if c components wants to get the
data from
a so a cannot directly pass the data to
c because
c is the child of b and b is the child
of a so according to the rule so data
has to be
passed through the proper hierarchy that
is what's called drilling down the props
which is one of the very very
complicated area because when you have a
complex hierarchy
and if you are making lot of middleman
in between so this create a lot of
confusion in your development and hence
your application gets more and more
complex
so to avoid such kind of scenarios so we
have this option like in
react context so in context api what
happens like here
the data can be passed directly
to any of the component whichever
needs that
so data gets stored in a centralized
environment and from there it get passed
down to all its child whenever it needs
whether it is a direct child or it is a
indirect so this is what the benefit you
get with the help of props here
so if you see the main comment have got
not many childs so using the props you
are passing the data to all its child
directly
but the challenge here is that all
childs are direct child of main
component what in case if we have
further
childs so that create a lot of trouble
okay so create context is basically the
way where you can pass a data directly
to
the components and cut down the all
middlewares
okay to your applications
and that's what the context api and the
question is like when to use a context
api
so as you can see it is clearly written
like context is basically designed to be
considered as a global state which any
of the components tree can easily get it
directly from its parent
okay without involving any of its style
directly
now
you see like here we have a call app
component which have the language as a
function
and here we have a course select
language so you are passing the data
here to its child
okay so you see here the language
component needs to take a very important
extra component that is known as call
what lang
and pass it to the selected language so
this could be further painful or more
complicated when on every single button
if the app needs to know the language
and what it is pass through the other
components so we want to basically cut
down all
so context if you want to use it
okay with using this areas like a
react.createcontext
so this create context helps you to
create a context in a parent component
whichever you want and let other
components subscribe to this so whenever
the changes are happened
they would be immediately informed about
that so here we have a call provider
so here every single context
okay so comes with the react provider so
they are basically trying to consume the
state whichever is being available with
the context
so using this property like in class or
context type you actually consume the
nearest current
of the context with using this dot
context
now we will call consumer
so this particular component which is
actually subscribing to the changes
okay so this let you
basically subscribe to the context with
the functional component and here you
have a call context to display name it
basically
accept a display name as a string
property
okay which you can easily drag through
when you talk about react dev tools
now let's talk about a demo
of our development
so now here
let's get involved on the demo part
but before that i would like to show you
one simple problem statement which you
feel it so this if you see we've got
context api which is available here so
here you can see this is
a property drilling where you are called
parent you have further childs and your
further childs so the component
properties keep on going through
multiple mediators
which you want to avoid
okay and the right hand side if you see
this one is basically the parent and
immediately passed on to her to the
child
and you see like here it is happening
this is the wrong approach where the
data is basically going to waterfall
model
this is better because here the data has
been passed from parent to any other
child directly
so that's what the benefit you get it
okay everybody so it's time to basically
talk about some
quick demo so that it can help us to
understand how we can utilize this react
context api for our development
so here
uh this is my project which is there
already developed
in my browser
i just when i open up i see here
in local 3000 i'm getting this as a
welcome message
so nothing fancy let's get started with
creating a new component i'm creating a
new folder
then you call
components and insert this i'm going to
create a new file
and give the name anything whichever i
want i say
index
dot
js or else i can use some different name
called
main app.js that looks fine
well here i need to import
okay import
react from react
well let's go back and start developing
a function so i'm developing
function
app
because i'm talking about functional
component
return
within this div tag i'm using this h2
tag
and now here we are seeing
welcome to app component
okay so that's a just a basic example we
have it
going ahead i would like to add few more
components like
function
imply
and the same thing
return
and here once again
okay
and here once again i'm saying h2
welcome to
employee component
okay
so
like this i can copy
and have one more that is called
salary and i'm saying
welcome to salary component
so these are the basic component sets
which are available to me
now certainly you will be having some
parent
and
employ
here
i would like to make
that means employees are com child of
app and
salary is a child of employee component
okay so it's very very simple
and straightforward
and later on
i can have
the new component ready
in which i can deploy
this
and make it available to the
end user
okay
so let's see what i'm having it now
so
here we have a call app
and here we are saying um
finally
equal to
i just give the name called main app
that looks more better
main app
and here we are using
react
dom
so we want to basically render it
wherever you want it
so or else what we can do is on the
other side
we can say
export
default
main app
we can do like this this mean i can add
it under my
app.js file
so it came from here and let's check
well i got this message printed here
so
this is
very simple and straightforward like you
in creating a parent and child
relationship
so now
the actual job comes
when my application is having
some of the details which i'm looking at
it
okay that means i want to have a data so
as i said earlier that when you are
creating
the react-based component so you need to
have some
relationships where the data can be
stored in anywhere so in the next
example i will show you how to store the
data in a main name and how we can pass
it to the others
now we will be providing the data to our
main component
which is my main app
so here i would like to provide
const
here we can have
because we're talking about state
management
so we're saying employee
employee
equal to
use
state
use state
and here
in our use state will provide some of
the important information like an id
suppose i say one zero one
and i say name
and i can just give the name called
admin
and uh
so we have a call id we have a con name
let's try to
[Music]
put it
okay
it has to be here
yeah id
uh name admin and now we're talking
about
location
we can say pune
and uh let's talk about
salary
and we can give any satellite like one
two three four five so
here we have got this uh quick
state which we have created
okay so the next thing is like once your
state is ready
okay so you have to provide some input
through which the data can be available
to the others
and to make this possible here
above this we are providing
const
employee context
equal to
react.greatcontext
so we are initializing our context
to confirm
what we're really doing this now
and in this context whichever i'm having
it now i would like to provide a data
which i can easily access to my other
components
so now here once i provide a context
here
okay so when i see this welcome to this
component you can see we have called
employee available
yeah so what i will be doing is now here
we will be saying
employ context
using employee context
dot
provider
okay
now here
we want to provide
close this
yeah so here we are providing value
value equal to
the value object so what value object we
are having it right now here
that is called employee
so this is state we are initially
providing it here
and
this
area wherever the context is basically
available will be providing this
employee object and pass it within this
so this employee object which we are
having it
so now you can see the context is closed
here so now within this context we have
passes employ so that all data will be
available to this employee object now
and that's the best part of this code
now
okay
now this context i can easily get it
in my employee
okay
and access all the details whichever i
wanted
now if i see here
i can come down and i say
let
context
equal to
now we are using this option i can use
context and inside this use context we
are talking about
employee context so we got the details
whatever we have set it on the top
okay and here
i can set
the details like we are saying welcome
to the employee component so we have got
a lot many things available here so
label
so let's provide details here
so we are saying employee id
colon
here
we can use the details
okay by saying
context dot you can see we have got
details available
like an id
likewise i can just copy it
paste it
employee name
typical employee name
so we also have a part of this
id name location so we can also pass
location
okay
so we have got those uh
details available with us
and in a similar line
whatever details we have taken it from
there i can also pass it where
in my salary component too
where i can display the salary related
details into my code so like here
i can just copy this here
okay so we got employee context which is
available
and here i can provide the same number
of amount
like but this time
i may require sorry
i may require the name
as well as the salary both
okay
so these two details
whichever you want you can easily get it
and make it available to the client
okay so this using use context
you're actually trying to retrieve all
the relevant information
which was required and you can see it is
available here so the same employee
which is there now i can have this
employee details
under my employee component and under my
salary
we have a call salary component so
that's something which makes
your context api more interesting
because this is where you avoid
bringing any middleware and make this
data
or component easily accessible outside
and so with that we come to the end of
this detailed tutorial on react.js
thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you